Elon Musk has bought Twitter it's uh not
completely done yet because there's
still got to be reviews there's there's
legal issues the the shareholders I
believe have to vote but uh in all
likelihood it's a done deal and we'll
see if Elon Musk is actually going to be
the hero in this one we don't know maybe
he won't change the rules right away we
will see how it will play out but most
people are saying this is great news
where everyone's cheering like oh Alex
Jones and Trump are going to come back
we'll we'll see we'll see Elon Musk has
said that he wants free speech we'll see
where his line is in free speech because
it's going to be an interesting
discussion I don't I don't even know
that Elon Musk will be able to tolerate
some of the things that are free speech
when it comes to what's going on with
Twitter so we will talk about that
mostly that there's a lot of other news
Trump is being held in contempt being
fined ten thousand dollar a day in a
civil court we've got uh um what else we
got Google is going to be doing weird
woke suggestions and uh like it's like
an auto correct thing so all of this is
mostly floating around what's happening
with Elon Musk and we really got to talk
about the ramifications here the deal
itself Twitter employees are reacting
they are imploding they are freaking out
blue check marks are saying the same
thing conservative said three years ago
and without a shred of irony or humility
this should be a lot of fun joining us
today to talk about all of this is Ron
basilian Ron how's it going hi Tim
pleasure to be here hey so do you want
to introduce yourself
wow I have a bit of a resume uh we met
back in 2018 at politicon when I was
running for congress in California's
37th I've been involved in uh Republican
politics in the LA GOP California GOP
uh overall major political presence on
on Twitter Ron for California that's
what the number four uh involved in City
politics over in Culver City a big shout
out to all my friends over there and uh
if you want to learn about local
politics hit me up I think people need
to get more involved in their local
communities whether it's in the you know
School Board races local races and you
know as I said I also wrote a graphic
novel Inferno Los Angeles like 10 years
ago so I'm seeing how you know New Media
is really able to take over like Legacy
Media
networks and right on yeah it should be
interesting Sheamus hanging out I'm
Sheamus from Freedom Tunes you all want
to check out the cartoons I make Go
YouTube Freedom Tunes I think you guys
will enjoy it coming out with another
cartoon this week I just rolled
100-sided die I'm gonna let you know
what it oh land on a 76 1776 Here Comes
Again
Taylor green got in trouble for that
buddy sorry Marge
um freedom of the American Spirit is a
beautiful thing so let's keep it going
tonight definitely it's so funny to me
that 1776 now means some form of
rebellion although I guess initially it
did against the British so I guess
that's a good thing we've come full
circle yes I'm excited for tonight it's
been a great conversation I'm very
excited that Elon Musk got Twitter
before we get started my friends head
over to
strongerbonesandlife.com to pick up your
ageless multi-collagen 51 off today I
went to a parkour gym over the weekend
it was a whole lot of fun and admittedly
I don't have that great upper body
strength because I skate so it's all
it's all leg workout every day so going
there my arms are really sore my joints
I'm an old the man I'm 36 so I got to
get this ageless multi-college and
actually put it in my weird lemonade
that I usually drink every day and it's
it's actually great it's good for your
skin your nails your joints and all that
stuff head over to stronger bones and
life.com you can get 51 off today you
will get a 60-day money-back guarantee
the healthy aging support of collagen in
ideal forms five key types of collagen
you need from four different sources
hydrolyzed collagen peptides meaning
better and faster digestibility to
support maximum benefits for every order
today they will donate a nutritious meal
to a hungry child in your honor through
their partnership with no kidhungry.org
to date BioTrust has provided over 5
million meals to Hungry kids please help
BioTrust hit their goal of six million
meals this year it is non-GMO and free
of artificial colors flavors
preservatives and sweeteners and free of
gluten antibiotics and rbgh and RBST
nearly no odor or taste unlike bone
broth no clumping unlike other collagen
supplements and actually yeah you can
see it in my drink there's no clumping
at all
all right you'll get free shipping with
every order free VIP live health and
health and fitness coaching from
BioTrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and their free e-report the 14 foods for
amazing skin with every order over at
stronger bones in life thank you very
much bad trust shout out don't forget to
head over to timcast.com where our
Newsroom was diligently working today
when I was recording my main segment I'm
like at any moment they're going to
announce Elon bought Twitter and so my
Newsroom is sending all these sources
and I'm pulling them into my segment in
real time shout out guys they are
employed thanks to all of you as members
if you like the work we are doing become
a member but I also have news
ladies and gentlemen if you are upset
that the mainstream media has been lying
if you are upset that Washington Post
doxed Libs of tick tock and then lied
about it well
I don't know what to tell you other than
I got a billboard in Times Square and
unless they reject it it should be up
tomorrow at 9am with your support as
members we're able to do things like
that
it basically calls it the Washington
Post saying democracy dies in darkness
that's why we're calling you out Taylor
Lorenz doxed lives of tick tock a simple
message and I I wanted to do it I
tweeted about it everyone said do it the
guys of the daily wire helped put
together Jeremy boring co-ceo said I got
half on it and I said let's do it
because they have these journalists have
the nerve to go on CNN and MSNBC or
wherever say all of these things and
just try to Gaslight us okay well you
know what we'll put up something in
Times Square it's not like we're sending
the message literally everywhere but
that's a big statement so that's what
we're going to be doing I'll put it this
way with your support as members we're
going to push back we are going to
engage in in culture change culture and
call people out using these institutions
and these machines I want to be uh I
want to be like like Elon Musk I want to
do what he does when he buys Twitter to
challenge the machine but I'm not a
billionaire so here's what we can do we
gotta we got a billboard in Times Square
hopefully it doesn't get rejected it
might we'll see what happens but uh
thanks for being members and making all
of that possible we're going to keep
fighting as a member you'll get access
to exclusive segment into the timcast
IRL podcast maybe we'll talk a bit more
about the billboard thing and people can
have some questions that being said
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends and ladies and gentlemen here we
are from timcast.com Elon Musk
successfully buys Twitter Twitter's
board reached a deal in the billion
dollar bid to sell Tesla CEOs uh Tesla
to sell to Tesla's CEO and take the
company private do you know what happens
on Thursday guys you tell me Freedom
Tunes uploads a new cartoon twitters
earnings report oh well that too and
what do you think that earnings report
would show
something good or something bad
bad something bad because Twitter's been
struggling for some time you look at any
news story of the past several months
and they say Twitter is lagging not
reaching its goals which means I'm
willing to bet Elon Musk played some 4D
chess he knew the earnings report was
coming up and he knew he had to act now
he offered 54.20 per share if on
Thursday news comes out that the
earnings were not good the stock would
likely Fall the board knows this they
know what their earnings are if they
rejected a 54.20 offer knowing that
their stock would be worth half that by
Thursday they would be liable for
damages for not adhering to their
fiduciary duty to the shareholders and
that could be what 20 billion dollars if
the earnings report came out and the
stock dropped to 40 or 30 bucks the
board's like nah I don't want to be
responsible for that money I don't want
to be sued for that just give them the
deal done
we'll see what the investors say we'll
see what this means but I think Elon
Elon Musk he cornered them masterfully
their uh their main source of their
earnings as far as I can tell is AD
Revenue uh it's a very risky proposition
for a company to roll that die because
if the advertisers get disenfranchised
or disgruntled they'll pull their their
money which means the Twitter is
basically an advertising firm no I call
Shenanigans shenanigans
Twitter banned ads that deny their their
opinions on climate change so if Twitter
is holding up their duty to their
shareholders they wouldn't they wouldn't
say no to advertisements on political
grounds
Twitter outright said we don't want your
money if you if you disagree on climate
science interesting do you think they
would try to make the argument that uh
you know taking money from those groups
would limit their ability to make a
profit in the future because they could
damage the reputation I don't think
that's going to work in court I don't
think it's just that I think that they
killed virality they made the site
boring because the board of directors
represents other companies which feels
like Twitter is worth more to them dead
than alive and so what you've got is a
Twitter that's dead under their reign
elon's like this company is worth a lot
to me alive it's worth a lot to me
if I can bring back the excitement of
viral content that comes from Twitter
when it was a free Marketplace of ideas
and my only regret about all of this is
that I don't get to take that ride with
Elon Musk anymore because shareholders
were all going to get bought out and
he's taking it private yes full
disclosure I have 22 shares through my
brokerage app when Elon Musk announced
he bought it I was like all right I'll
open up my account I had a thousand
bucks and I clicked buy and I think I'll
end up making like 100 bucks yeah not
bad thanks Elon I will I will buy a
delicious Umami Burger so what you're
saying is that this show is funded by
Elon Musk this is propaganda lately
you've just acknowledged it we've lost
all credibility it costs 100
per 10 years per decade to run this
that's all it is and you know that
hundred dollars funds everything no I
think um
I think Twitter is not upholding it's
fiduciary duty they banned political ads
why
they banned anti-climate change ads why
I I get it you might disagree with it
but why would a for-profit company say
we don't want money from legitimate
advertisers
yeah because there's they're playing
politics they were using their ads as a
political statement probably this this
one just happened too and I was kind of
like do I need to sue over this because
I got to tell you man that one
like when they announced that they were
Banning political ads I'm like okay
there's a potential there's a potential
argument here they could say in order to
maintain the health of the platform and
I don't mean their kind of Health I mean
like people using the platform we don't
want to be dominated by just big
spatterings of political ads the money
would actually cause more damage the ads
would the climate change thing makes no
sense conservatives would love it yeah
like and the left would hate it no I
hear you on that I'm just curious if
it's an argument that they would make if
they would say something like people see
advertisements from these groups we're
going to lose our credibility as a
website and I get that but but a judge
is going to be like except 80 plus
million people in this country yeah
agree with those ads or people are are
swayed by those it's not an argument
like you could you could imagine them
arguing oh man you know Millennials
don't like drinking soda you know this
this is actually true Millennials don't
drink soda so those Coca-Cola ads are
really bad for our credibility I mean
sure but I'm not going to blame you know
downtown Chicago for the ad that gets
put up on the billboard off the highway
that's ridiculous I feel like this uh
there's still like a it's a 12 year old
business model they're still running off
of advertising which is like very 2010.
they have an opportunity to spin up a
utility token
um to streamline F activity on the
website where you could spend one
Twitter token to get a thousand views on
Twitter like mines does that's another
Revenue model you could have direct to
subscriber uh uh payments which like
your subscribers could pay you directly
as a user of Twitter Twitter could take
like one percent and then that could be
a new Revenue model for the site
Dogecoin tips oh my gosh yeah I know
that musk is involved well I'll ask you
guys would you be willing to pay for
Twitter I do curious about this you do
yeah so you wouldn't what about you I'm
not but who knows I think Elon Musk is
going to be very imaginative about
offering premium features that I would
actually want I think a big issue for
conservatives or just people who are not
you know speaking the company line on
Twitter is like why would I bother
spending any money when it's obvious
that this site does what they can to
throw model what I say on here and I
think it's a common perception of
Twitter and you know I think if nothing
else Elon Musk is going to at least
make it transparent and have some
consistent policies and say you know
you're getting throttled because of this
algorithm or you got banned because of
this policy and be like okay that's fair
you know and maybe even provide ways to
remedy that to be so people can get
reinstated but you know it's like we've
seen so many people who acted in good
faith and had good arguments and were
like really good viral accounts that got
banned because some passive aggressive
nitwit and behind the scenes just decide
I don't like this guy I'm Banning them
Alex Jones that's obvious
project Veritas and James O'Keefe very
obvious Carl Benjamin AKA Sargon of
akkad also obvious I miss him every day
on Twitter and then you've got the of
course Miley Annapolis Laura Loomer who
who else the president of the United
States
I mean the Trump the Trump one is a
special class I get it of itself like
I'm I was just trying to name people
like who are the obviously Trump lives
of tick or not Libs um Babylon B I think
oh yeah
supposedly is the reason he decided to
buy Twitter I don't agree but that was
like the the straw that broke the
camel's bag
Carpe dongtum was for those that are
familiar a meme Smith who just made
memes and was banned for literally no
reason none
and you know then you have all the
people that were posting like
interesting vaccine facts you know and
that just went against the company line
they did their research and everything
and it was like your band because we
believe the vaccine is safe for most
people even the disclaimer was like safe
for most people what does that mean
unsafe for a lot of people that's the
really good way to lawyer the answer you
can't say it wasn't even about that I
mean anything that could come from a
doctor if the doctor disagreed with some
doctor Twitter chooses like we can't
live this way we can't live in a world
where big Tech is like here's the
approved doctors and their opinions
right I can understand the idea of of
consensus in that there are a lot of
people and and the majority of research
looks in this direction
but it's just an insane way to live
where we say we will actually ban
dissenting opinion that's the opposite
of science so my point ultimately here
when it comes to Trump when it comes to
Alex Jones when it comes to Miley
Annapolis when it comes to lower Limer
these people did nothing illegal they
were banned because they did things that
Twitter did not like
if Elon is to restore Free Speech all of
these people get reinstated well this is
a long conversation I don't think that
having one authoritarian gives the
company to another authoritarian to make
the decision necessarily means Free
Speech because if it's if we're relying
on elon's good faith to unban people and
then he still retains the right to ban
anybody at any time if he sells the
company or something happens to him
someone else takes over this is It's
just exactly where it was so it might
look like Free Speech but really you
need to get that get rid of that code
you need that code to be he said he
wants to open source the algorithm right
and that's the big issue to me I don't
think the unbanning is even going to be
number one it's going to be make the
code transparent hunt down all these bot
Farms because I think that's the big
thing you know you post anything
you know I was talking about the torture
of Joe Biggs in in federal prison and
you get people saying he deserves to be
tortured because he's an insurrectionist
I'm like who are you oh bought a27z5 you
know like get off of my timeline what
are you doing here you know I developed
the whole algorithm for it
ronfer37.org
n-a-a-h it's like how can you tell if
something is a bot new automated uh
Anonymous and hostile those that's the
the algorithm and they all fit the mold
and they're just Twitter is full of them
and and people that's what's making
Twitter boring I'm not here to argue
with Bots I want to argue with real
people I want to discuss with real
people that's what Elon wants to do he
wants to make it so that um and I think
this was his proposal five dollars a
month for Twitter blue and you get
verified I agree with it absolutely I
have mixed feelings because that just
feels like a pay-to-play model that if
if the five bucks yeah if the US
government wants to find a thousand
people that are going to toe the line
and give them all five bucks a month to
do it it does those people aren't more
valid than me who doesn't feel like
paying the money he says everybody human
is going to have the chance to get
verified but it's the humans that are
getting paid by like a nefarious actor
to be there that I wonder like how is
that gonna make them seem more value
because they spent five bucks the Bots
aren't a human you can have one human
Manning like a hundred different bot
accounts that's what's happening this is
my joke is like there's either a DNC or
pentagon on office somewhere where
somebody's running all of these but then
you're talking about having them verify
their actual personality with like a
social security number or an address
which is extremely dangerous to
centralize that data or an ID yeah if
you if you centralize that data on a on
some database people from all around the
world can seize it and sell it and to
find out where you live and what what
your credit card information is but but
that argument
you're arguing that I mean every single
website does that uh I've been looking
into what's called decentralized
identity there's ways for you to have an
identity online that isn't necessarily
for sure but let's let's keep the
context to Twitter because what you're
saying is just some idea of something
that might happen but Elon is doing
nothing different from literally any
other website um you trade crypto you
got to verify your identity to trade
crypto I worry about some of those
websites frankly that's because there's
a financial incentive like with mines
too you can spend money with like mines
plus so that you're able to send the
mines tokens off the network onto your
own personal wallet so there's a
financial value to spending money per
month but if it's just to show everyone
that you're you're realistic I don't
think you have to understand what your
argument against Elon Musk is though it
sounds like you're saying the internet
itself has a problem okay to verify is
not my is not a solution to verification
I can't that doesn't verify but let's
let's say he goes for the humans get
verified model if you're if you're human
you can choose verification that's
originally Twitter verification was to
prove you weren't a robot
because they were robot accounts and
they were like you can verify that and
if someone makes a parity account or
whatever you have you're in Cross and
it's your image you've verified it yeah
it's to keep popular accounts from
getting
um mimicked or you know fake no no the
original the original purpose was just
to prove you were a real person to prove
you were the person behind the account
it had nothing to do with stopping
mimicry uh or or imitation or or
anything like that eventually they said
we can't scale this up so they gave up
they said we're not going to verify
people anymore we're closing
verification requests it's only going to
be for the celebrities we choose because
we don't want to deal with it this led
to a huge backlash where people are like
verifications of Badge of like
authenticity Twitter you get special
features when you're verified that other
people don't get run for office that'll
get you verified or work for a major
corporation who can make that phone call
so one of the things he wants to do is
you can be verified good and then I'll
just be like verified accounts only
please I'm not gonna I'm not gonna argue
with an account with one follower that's
like the 80th account some guy's running
because he bought 10 phone owns to do it
or a company or some like some what was
that what was that Democrat company that
did sock puppies I'm not gonna we'll
avoid naming them for for legality
reasons but
you've got political firms that will
hire one guy to run 50 accounts and
pretend to be 50 people to try and sway
public opinion to harass you get rid of
all of that that'll make the platform
healthier absolutely and you can tell
who the Bots are because they're all
coming from the same IP address this is
what I said like let's look at what the
IP address of some of these Bots are I
mean we don't have to make it fully
transparent but
you know Elon and the engineers at
Twitter can take a look at that it
shouldn't be that hard to notice who the
Bots are that way there's two like um I
guess ethos of of running social media
There's real identity real ID where they
can like track you down to the to the
way you poop in the day and then there's
Anonymous ID where they have no idea who
you are and they're both valuable like
if you have a totalitarian regime and
you're on Twitter they're going to know
exactly where you are and what you're
saying they'll find you and get you but
if you have Anonymous accounts you're
able to have a revolution against a a
corrupted establishment
um you don't have to be verified yeah I
was going to say isn't it possible to
not be verified
forcing you to verify if I'm not
verified you're going to set yours so
that you can only get responses from
people that are there's gonna be people
that aren't verified that don't want to
play that because they won't spend that
money and then there's going to be like
nobodies that are getting the government
agencies paying their five dollars a
month that are going to seem like valid
that's the thing about politics you find
very quickly if you want to have an
opinion you gotta step up and and stand
up for yourself if I'm out in in in
public and I see a bunch of people
wearing masks all yelling things I will
hold their opinion to less value than
someone standing up with with identity
revealed I understand the value of
anonymity for that reason depending on
the things people are talking about I
respect people's right to it but if I
know who you are I know what's behind
you I know what you stand for and why I
have more reason to trust you I'm a huge
advocate of people making videos for
that reason because you cannot fake it
when you make a video they see your face
they see your mouth get out of the text
in general that's I've been talking
about this since 2006 so I'm fully on
board with getting behind your own words
but there are times and places where
it's very dangerous and I don't think
those people should be shut out of the
conversation but also wait a couple
years on the video front man that
stuff's getting easier and easier to
fake I I agree Ian but what you're
saying is it's it's its preference now
if somebody wants to distribute an
anonymous uh pamphlet or something you
can still do it the people who are
sharing the founding fathers ideas were
doing it as themselves but the ideas
behind it were underpin names are suit
so no one knew who's actually writing it
but people were sharing it they weren't
posting it as like anime characters I
mean look I interact with plenty of
anonymous accounts you know but they act
in good faith they make good arguments
you know and and so I listen to them and
that's been the interesting thing about
Twitter is there is a sort of natural
Prestige system where people who make
interesting insights honest statements
you know that are valuable their
engagement goes up their followers go up
and they become you value their opinion
more than some random who comes in and
calls you a poopy awesome question
should titanium McGrath be verified
[Music]
that's an interesting concept I mean is
is uh yeah it would be a legit but it
would be a legitimate parody site and
you want to like it's not exactly huh
it's not a website so I'd say no well no
but there could be imitators would I
don't know it's just something to think
about I'm curious I mean do fictional
characters ever get check marks on
Twitter to verify that it's an official
account I guess Mickey Mouse or
something is making it interesting yeah
let me look into that Disney trademark
properties well while you're looking
that up let's jump to this story we have
this from the post millennial Twitter
employees go absolutely insane after
Elon Musk buys the company quote I feel
like I'm going to throw up I really
don't want to work for a company that's
owned by Elon Musk well Welcome to the
Real World the craziest part take a look
at this from Bloomberg Twitter locks
down product changes after agreeing to
musk bed the fear is that Rogue
employees will nuke the platform so they
had to lock everything down that's how
crazy things have gotten now there's one
funny tweet that I want to highlight
Sean Davis from he's at the Federalist
right CEO and co-founder of the
Federalist he tweets uh this from Talman
Smith who says quote
a part of what I do I'm sorry Talman
Smith is quoting somebody else I don't
want it's not a tribute to him quote a
part of what I do is monitoring toxicity
and health in the trends I don't know if
this will impact my job directly I want
to still have a job and I don't know how
this impacts that they added they're
pretty broken wish I had a nuanced take
on it but I'm just scared and sad well I
will tell you how this buyout will
affect your job uh it won't because you
won't have one ha ha now I I think Elon
Musk will keep a lot the same
I think the first thing that's going to
happen is he'll have to go in and learn
how the Machine Works then he'll
probably throw up into a couple paper
bags realizing what's going on behind
the scenes both because people post
horrifying things and both because the
censorship and manipulation is worse
than anyone realized and then he'll try
to get a handle on it yeah I mean this
is part of what's so golden about this
entire thing you have all these Twitter
employees absolutely losing their minds
just behaving like unhinged Maniacs as
if we're supposed to see that and go oh
man I'm sorry that they don't have free
reign anymore yeah I don't really want
scared and sad people running my Twitter
accounts exactly just so you know
squared and sad guy and this was exactly
the reaction everybody predicted right I
mean they're like yeah we finally got
rid of Donald Trump because he's such a
poopy head I couldn't stand him like why
is that your decision
shouldn't be I don't think any any one
person should have the reins on that
kind of power right now well and again
they have played their hand they're
showing that these are not cool calm and
collected people who can make reasonable
decisions in a time of Crisis look at
the way they're acting right now Eli
someone they don't like now has control
of their company they're all they're in
histrionics now I'm just doing some math
I'm looking as of December 21 there's
more than 7 500 Twitter employees that's
a lot of people and Elon is is pretty I
would call him Cutthroat what would you
say you do here yeah exactly they work
at home that was a big part of this
Twitter thread too that Tim had pulled
up earlier as they were saying most of
Twitter employees work from home now
they're wondering if that's going to
change I think that he's going to slash
them this is what I said what would
happen if Elon Musk just shut down the
VPN locked out all the employees except
for the knocks at the data center would
Twitter become a better website just
from that
what would that look like exactly you
wouldn't have these toxicity moderators
for one I mean I don't know
yeah toxicity firearm
you know you know Elon Musk is in for a
rude awaken I gotta be I got to be
honest I think it's a smart guy I think
he's he's planned strategically I think
he cornered Twitter the shareholders may
still try and push back but I really
don't see what their what their votes
are going to be I mean you're getting
free money but let me I think Ian
understands this especially having
worked with Minds when Ian said when uh
when when Eon when Elon it's getting to
that I fused them both yes you did Sir
when Elon says he wants free speech
I don't think he understands truly what
that will mean to open the floodgates
and I think even Elon Musk must have a
line so I'll put I'll pose this
it is free speech
to show images of dead babies because
you want people to know about the
horrors of what's going on with abortion
say right James yeah and so how will
people know they don't want it unless
they can see what's actually happening
will advertisers want to be on a
platform where there are photos of dead
babies it's an interesting question to
be fair I think what Eon musklin
thong for like how many times before I
finally realized I did not want to see
that
yeah no it's an interesting question I
think this is a really complicated
problem that not a lot of people
consider which is that even with these
conservative Alternatives that they're
trying to launch if any of them ever
happen to catch on or even with this
what muskie's trying to do implementing
a more neutral model with respect to
speech at some point you're right it
could affect profitability and then what
happens then yeah I think the the ad
Revenue model is dying it's it's useless
well it's getting to the point where
it's useless that's why Elon says he
wants to drive up memberships so well I
just want to I like what Eon musklin no
I like what Elon Musk is saying uh about
a lot of this but here's what I'm
curious about without looking at this
through any ideological framework Tim
you were sort of mentioning earlier that
restricting certain advertisers from
being able to pay Twitter to have their
ads placed there could be failing to
fulfill their fiduciary responsibility
do you think there's an argument to be
made that the shareholders allowing
unfettered Free Speech could also be
failing to uphold their fiduciary
responsibility because it could make the
company less profitable
I would argue uh I I will actually
addressed that I said when it when it
comes to politics the board might
actually argue that taking on some
advertisers would hurt us which is why
they justify it but climate change
there's no there's no justification for
that no no I agree with you I guess my
point is Will no no my point is
do you think that's going to pose a
threat to Elon being able to make this a
free speech platform are they going to
say we are failing to fulfill our free
lawyers
oh that's right he's thinking of private
I couldn't believe it yeah you're right
right yeah which means he could go on
and he can read your DMs Elon can that's
right into anyone you know you gotta
understand what he's buying right now
he's buying the ability to DM
Britney Spears he's gonna find the
ability to read his ex's messages well
like somebody somebody who who's who's
this Madonna who's who's his age Eminem
Elon Musk now has the power to open up
DMS to anyone he wants he owns it it's
his well let me ask you a question would
you rather own the Washington Post or
Twitter not even a question you know the
answer to that one man so so who's ahead
in the billionaire game Jeff Bezos or
Elon Musk oh Bezos says and we know this
because he's trying to throw shade at
musk on Twitter
but Bezos bought Washington Post for
like 200 million right yeah Elon put up
44 billion
um it was funny elon's or I'm sorry uh
Bezos said something along the lines of
does China now have a stake in the
Public Square in response to Elon Musk I
want to go back to that to the Free
Speech point I was making before Elon
Musk has a line and his and AWS which
Twitter is on right it's on AWS yeah oh
actually I don't know if Twitter is
Twitter's twitters they might have their
own infrastructure I suppose I think
they have their own info I would not
trust AWS well yeah but Twitter would I
mean they're bored what 2020 Twitter
chooses AWS there you go exactly so what
happens when Elon Musk says I want
unfettered free speech which results in
let's just be real well the people who
are even on the left who are going to
masquerade as the right saying racial
slurs yeah so that Elon musk's so the
the the the the the the chain link in
the infrastructure of Twitter re revolts
against him so you're going to have AWS
saying we won't Host this because
there's people posting untoward content
you're gonna have the app stores saying
until you clean this up Elon Musk can
take Twitter
but everything around him can you know
the entirety of Silicon Valley can
surround him and shut him down so how
how much could Elon Musk tolerate how
much can Twitter tolerate and then
how much can they withstand a barrage
from Silicon Valley he may be the world
the world's richest man but the combined
wealth and power of the entirety of
Silicon Valley and Venture Capital
surrounding it I don't think he he can
be he can beat that no well that's what
I'm saying like expanding free speech
and unbanning people is probably going
to be very late in the game right now he
just wants to develop a consistent set
of policies that are transparent and
that for them to have a problem with
that would be revealing more about
themselves and about Elon and I'll give
you another idea Does Elon taking over
Twitter embolden a Mark Zuckerberg to
allow Facebook to become a bit more free
and transparent because he's getting the
same pressures that Elon Musk is and
it's killing Facebook what did their
stock Drop Like one-third in one night
they can use as an as an excuse and say
in order for us to compete now we've got
a private company worth 50 billion
dollars and it's one of the biggest
social social media Platforms in the
world they're allowing of free speech is
making people want to leave our platform
sorry shareholders it is our fiduciary
duty we must start unbanning I don't
know if they'll do it because I think
they're they're ideologically driven not
profit driven but that's a possibility
but I think that's a difference we have
I don't think it's an issue of
shareholders it's you know an issue of
political pressure I mean we were
talking about how like this you know
California politicians were telling
Facebook and Twitter banned these guys
censor those guys Barack Obama is coming
on saying that there's too much trash on
the internet it needs to be banned you
have political figures in this country
who are openly advocating against the
First Amendment and using their
political muscle to make these private
companies do their bidding something
about Free Speech when we talk about
Free Speech we got to Define it firstly
it's the American the United States of
America's version of it is enshrined in
the Constitution that kind of free
speech where you can't say certain
things in that kind of free speech so
that isn't translating to the internet
doesn't translate to the internet you
can't it's they're all authoritarian
networks that are owned by someone that
can ban anything at any time yeah
there's no free speech yeah so saying
bring free speech to Twitter doesn't
it's it's a non-sequitur it doesn't make
sense even even gab doesn't have
absolute Free Speech no and nor should
spam is a new a new phenomenon and and
Dachshund because we all agree okay
dachshund crosses the line Sean even
Andrew torbov gab said that like you
said showing pictures of like gruesome
stuff that's free speech but you don't
you know there's times Well if it's up
to the authoritarian owner of the
company whether that should be allowed I
understand that but so so I I would say
people typically say free speech is the
expression of political thoughts ideas
Etc and so we try to understand in that
in that framework spam doesn't fit that
if someone is trying to shut down the
conversation by screaming some would
argue that's not free speech that's just
screaming in fact that's shutting people
down there's there's also species
there's also property rights so if
someone comes into your business and
they start telling you something you
don't want to hear you can kick them out
of the building and the government can't
say no you have to let them sit there
free speech you have to make their cake
foreign
if I come into your establishment you
can kick me out for any reason not if
you say if you come to the restaurant
and start talking about your your
protected your protected status you can
ask me to leave your premises at any
moment for any reason that's probably
right so it's part of your property
that's not that's not true I mean give
me an example the 1964 Civil Rights Act
protects special classes uh in public
accommodation meaning I'm talking about
private accommodation this is all
private Twitter's a private company
right well no hold on hold on you
misunderstand public accommodation means
like a McDonald's it's privately owned
but it's open to the public if I walk in
and say and scream something like my dog
you know bites strangers and they say
please sir be quiet and you won't they
can kick you out if you go in and start
screaming something about a protected
class now they're in in a troubled
situation if they kick you out they
could argue he was screaming of course
the individual say I went in there and
started saying I am this protected class
so they kicked me out that's where it
gets money okay if you're saying
McDonald's is a public accommodation
then I'm open to that argument I just
have McDonald's is a public
accommodation yeah public accommodations
are like services and buildings that are
open to the public so like Tim kiss is a
business it's private property it is not
a public accommodation people can't come
here Wendy's is because they they want
you to come into their building but that
means they have to under the I believe
the 1964 Civil Rights Act they cannot
deny so they they can put up signs all
day and night saying we reserve the
right to refuse service to anybody you
get into muddy territory because of
course you can kick someone out for
screaming but if they're screaming
things about a protected class their
argument in court will now go up against
yours and they're are you saying that if
like a homeless person goes into a
Wendy's and just goes to sleep in one of
the booths that they can't kick the
person no you can kick the person out
but like if you kick a person out just
because they're a protected class and
they can prove that in court then they
got a case against you pick them up for
for loitering yes right so Ian if a
black person walked into a Wendy's the
manager can't say you're loitering get
out technically they can but we all see
what happens they lose in court but my
point is technically media goes goes off
and says they're racist yeah there might
be a cultural backlash but technically
no no Ian it is not all right arguing
about this anymore my point is Twitter
can ban anyone at any time for any
reason they don't need a reason that's
mostly because of section 230. they
actually have a special provision that
allows them to bypass the public
accommodation provision of the of the
1964 Civil Rights Act this was always
the craziest thing to me that you can't
deny someone access to public to a
public accommodation on the basis of
certain specialized classes or you know
identities or whatever but Twitter gets
to because of section 230 meaning quite
literally someone can post that they
believe in gay marriage and Twitter can
say no you don't ban and I'm like but
wait a minute it's because I forgot I
forgot it was explained to me by a
lawyer it may have been Will Chamberlain
I'm not sure but someone explained that
uh the expression of opinion is not
you know the same thing as denying
someone's service because of who they
are so like if you say I will not
provide you service you have to leave
because of this thing about you and I
just said that's ridiculous because they
could just argue that's why they got
banned and basically the broad
protections of section 230 make it
impossible to win on that front now if
you want to talk about is this company a
public accommodation I don't know I feel
like it's very fascist to for a
government to tell a private company
what they have to do with their company
You could argue that there's monopolies
and that's the government's jobs to
break up monopolies well that's the big
issue right and they say like well what
this person said is very offensive but
then like I said in the past two years
you've had people make very reason very
cogent arguments that are not at all
offensive but because they go against
like the financial interests of
BlackRock you know they get banned I
mean that is a much
there is no philosophical case against
that right that's purely a political
case there
um well I don't know if it you know I
mean with the with the lockdowns I mean
you saw it more than anything people
didn't want children getting masked
people were getting tired of the
lockdowns the lockdowns weren't doing
anything but they were getting banned
for saying it you know I mean just look
at the trucker Convoy in Canada
so so my my point earlier on though
because I think people at least some
people misunderstand free speech on
Twitter means people will be saying
we'll be responding to every post or the
racial slur it means there there will be
people who will do that you have the
option to block them that's reality if
you want to go out to the Town Square
you're going to hear people screaming
nasty things that they're going to be
holding up really awful signs and that's
reality you can't hide from it Twitter
seems to think that they wanted to craft
this utopian world where they would
decide what things were toxic and what
things weren't
we'll see if Elon Musk will tolerate
that because either he says Free Speech
or he decides from his own personal
morals some things are okay and some
things aren't
I'm looking up this uh Federal
accommodations public accommodations
things you can't discriminate on basis
of race color religion or national
origin or disabilities right but I but a
private company could still toss you out
if they just don't like the way you
smell right yes okay so the issues the
issue arises when you have a person who
is a protected class and they and you
don't like the way they smell then
they're gonna be like oh it's my race
and you'll be like no it's because you
were stinking up the inside and then
they'll say we'll see you in court and
you'll lose and guess what you will
maybe that's it that's an issue and
we're in La where some tweaker will come
into establishment and start harassing
people and even getting into fights and
at that point you gotta friggin wrestle
them out establishment I feel like all
this argument about free speech on the
Internet is a facade a fallacy there is
none you cannot have free speech in a
private company good luck trying to you
got to fix the way that that is built
I've told you how to do it in the past
you free the software code you get it
off your back let other people spin up
their own twitters with their are all in
terms of service so you can pick the one
that works you're contradicting yourself
and they all interoperate I don't think
so you are if you said that there can't
be free speech on the internet well
there can be you just explained how to
do it
you can give different networks the
ability to choose to have free speech on
them if they want but you can't make
someone give you free speech I think
this what do you mean like if you walk
into a place where you're not wanted and
you say what you think is your right to
say they can they can stop you not
everyone can cancel you off on the
internet they can so uh we talked about
this with uh Occupy Wall Street it's
what's called a privately owned public
space yeah and the courts ruled that
even though it's privately owned because
it's a park open to the public this is
Ducati they had to allow protest
so I argued Twitter should be the same
way a privately owned public space sure
you can privately own it you can put up
whatever Billboards you want but if it
is a speech business open to the public
you should not be able to borrow people
for protest yeah Ian I get what you're
saying it's a complicated question but
there was actually a Supreme Court
decision Marsh vs Alabama in the 1940s
and they basically determined that in a
company town they were not able to
prohibit a woman from passing out
religious literature because it was
protected by the First Amendment even
though it was their private property
I think it has something to do with
taking up a certain amount of the Public
Square that you are now required to
uphold the law of the land oh that's
okay in the United States it is the
first time so she came into my house and
started passing out religious stuff I
can't say you can't do that but I can
say get out of my house yeah so well my
understanding and again I'm not a legal
expert I'm not an expert on this case by
any means I've heard a bit about it but
my understanding is basically that if
you own a large enough or you occupy a
large enough percentage of a Public
Square as a private business there are
certain First Amendment responsibilities
that you have there's a back and forth
on this actually in the state of
California where malls are technically
supposed to allow people to leaflet and
do political activity but then they sort
of go back and say no we have the right
to regulate in the interest of keeping
the mood of our mall so like for example
you go to some malls are like okay you
can go set up a table over there but you
have to like you know file an
application and give a deposit and all
that we ignore those when I when I was
doing fundraising they would tell you
and this happened all the time go to a
shopping center you're allowed to work
for causes and fundraise and and protest
they will tell you you can't they will
tell you they're calling the police they
can't do anything and if the police show
up the police will defend you and sure
enough every time the police came up
apologize to me and just said ignore
them you're allowed to if like you're
outside you're on you're in a parking
lot outside waving to people as long as
you're not being you're not obstructing
anybody as long as you're not screaming
anybody you're just waving and handing
out flyers and asking people to talk
totally fine protect it under the first
amendment I think part of why I'm
concerned with what you were saying
about treating Twitter as part of the
commons and just letting it Fly is how
will you moderate that
who's been charged and of moderating it
like if it's a private company and
you're like you can't moderate it the
way you want now figure out how to
moderate it that doesn't make any sense
how do we moderate the public we have
police okay we have police problem
solved right well we have laws and
things of the Constitution the guides
the actions if someone if someone posts
something illegal which there are many
things illegal under the law then
there you go the police get called
intervene arrest the person and then if
it's if if elon's Twitter decides we're
going to immediately remove any any
anything made any anything made uh were
made aware of that's illegal will be
removed instantly the police will be
informed trespassing is illegal so if
you're on Twitter if you're in their
space so that's it's just a different
environment
well I just want to read one sentence
from this decision that I pulled up here
uh justice Hugo L black noted that and
quote here the more an owner for his
Advantage opens up his property for use
by the public in general the more do his
rights become circumscribed by the
statutory and constitutional rights of
those who use it so I I having making a
private company
act as if it's the United States
government is challenging I agree that
these things are in the Commons I do
believe they are in the comments far far
right in Crossland free market I don't
think that forcing Twitter to change its
its terms makes any sense it's super
dangerous precedent if the government
starts deciding what companies have to
how they have to behave or F but we're
not right now it's just a private a guy
has bought it and he's going to change
it the way sees fit
yeah okay maybe let's let's let's let's
go to the store right here we got this
from timcast.com Donald Trump says he
will not return to Twitter after Elon
must purchase the platform he'll make
improvements to it but I am going to be
staying on Truth said Trump oh boy I
don't think Trump is actually on Truth
he's not posting anything has he no I
don't know I'm not on it and I don't
think anyone else is either
I mean I I have an account there I don't
use yeah whatever I don't have one quote
Trump told Fox News I am not going on
Twitter I am going to stay on truth I
hope Elon buys Twitter because he'll
make improvements to it and he's a good
man but I'm going to be staying on Truth
we're making millions we're taking in
millions of people and what we're
finding is that the response on truth is
much better than being on Twitter that's
just fundamentally not true and anyone
of influence knows it all of these
conservatives are pointing out that the
left won't leave the platform Twitter is
the place you got to be because of
platform Monopoly are you saying that
the liar lied
yeah what I was going to say here is
that I think um you know it's very Noble
and I would argue in many ways a good
thing when conservatives try to start
their own Platforms in this sphere but
the problem is Twitter's utility is the
fact that basically everybody's on it
and your perspective can be heard by
people who didn't just come to hear a
right-wing perspective so you actually
have the possibility of changing
people's minds about things and so if
Elon Musk is able to make Twitter or I
should say Eon
um Muslim is able to make mush is able
to make Twitter a more fair and open
platform for different political views
that would be much better for us as a
movement than to all you know segregate
ourselves to this conservative website
that other people aren't seeing I'd like
to pull up this uh this tweet from how
do you say this guy's name Robert Wright
Roberto Reich oh man I think it's Reich
is it is it right right I'd like to pull
out this tweet um the sweet from him in
which he basically copies a tweet from
me from seven years ago or whatever he
says musk and his apologists say if
consumers don't like what he does with
Twitter they can go elsewhere but where
else would consumers go to post short
messages that can reach millions of
people other than Twitter the free
market increasingly reflects the demands
of big money it's called platform
Monopoly it's bad for our democracy as
well as our economy well you know what
Robert too effing bad you've lost any
good faith response from me in this in
this effort because you and your ilk
have spent the entirety of the past six
years burning everything to the ground
spitting in the face of people who had
political disagreements with you and now
that you're poised to lose you think you
can come back and say oh this platform
Monopoly is a big problem well that's
what I was saying what seven years ago
and now and now that you've come
crawling back I say this you don't get
to wage war and then once you start
losing or fear losing come and beg for a
ceasefire I'm not playing that Elon Musk
is going to be doing exactly what well
we're hoping that Elon Musk will do what
we've been hoping someone would do with
Twitter and that is bring free speech so
you don't have to leave Robert you get
to stay and say all of your dumb things
to everybody and we are not calling for
you to be banned we just want the rules
to be transparent we want people who are
suspended for BS fake reasons like Carpe
dongtum to be reinstated and you can go
cry about platform and Monopoly
somewhere else because we've all been
and we've all been taking issue with
that for some time your your complaints
are duly noted and duly ignored does
that article show his tweet from like
three years ago where he said it's a
private company and could do it at once
yeah he said literally how it started
where it's going or no it's sweet that
everyone's highlighting and they're
pointing it out as hypocritical he said
that the people complain about the First
Amendment on Twitter failed to realize
the private company and they can do what
they want he's not wrong the first
amendment is pertaining to government
restriction however most people aren't
saying the First Amendment if he wants
to highlight truly ignorant people who
are incorrectly saying the first
amendment by all means he can go and do
that most people who believe in free
speech are talking about the principle
of free speech one in which the first
amendment protects but exists outside of
the Constitution the principle of free
speech is that we respect that other
people will say things we don't like in
the public discourse
Twitter does not respect Free Speech
Facebook YouTube none of these platforms
do Twitter used to web 1.0 was truly a
glorious time I just remember that oh
yeah web 1.0 yeah I don't know the lack
of self-awareness is astounding I mean
look I never exactly pictured him as the
kind of person who is really in touch
with what people who disagreed with him
were saying or thinking but you have to
have literally not heard a single thing
a conservative has said for the past
five years to make this point and think
you're saying anything be fair Sheamus
yeah if these people are only watching
CNN of course that's the case no exactly
exactly but to have a political platform
that large when you have no idea what
the other side is saying is that's what
drives me as the Free Speech the term
Free Speech it's like free speech they
don't it's like a buzzword it's free
free code big networks need free code
not free speech Free Speech who's
deciding the owner of the network you
can't tell them what to do okay all I'm
saying is Robert Reich should be more
like me and know enough about his
opponent's position to make fun of them
in short form cartoons what is it about
our intellectual class where they get so
much stuff so so desperately wrong
exactly and this is what's so depressing
it's not as if we have an intellectual
class which is mediocre we have an
intellectual class which is stupid
they're dumb they're really
unintelligent I think they're affluent
is it affluenza um
I think it's Pride I think Pride blinds
people I think they have to push a
certain company line and they doesn't
matter how they lie or get stuff wrong
to achieve it there's just company line
you got to put out and you gotta stick
with it and if you stray from that
company line you no longer have a job
well the question is does he believe
this
or is he just as you're saying trying to
tell the company line does he think it
would be an effective strategy because
my point is whether he believes it or
not to think that it's an effective
strategy to out yourself as a hypocrite
so blatantly to me is bizarre come on
they do it every day yeah it's uh
something you learn about frauds they're
stupid and they're Liars there's no
division there right rational people
have that division there are people
right now fair enough that are
complaining because Al Franken basically
was forced to resign in disgrace over
the photo where he was you know grabbing
that woman's chest and they're
complaining about this medicine
cawthorne photo where he's got women's
lingerie on at a drinking on a cruise at
a party and I can't remember who tweeted
it but they were like Al Franken was
forced to resign over something much
less salacious than this and it's like
no he wasn't he assaulted a woman like
Madison cawthorne's in a chair drinking
at a party and doing silly things call
him say it's inappropriate fine whatever
it's a party but he didn't grab and
assault someone and he's actually
representing most Americans well so my
point is very awake women right next to
the point is that they're they're
creating this false hypocrisy where they
try and pull things up they're like aha
this is hypocritical and it's like dude
Robert Reich tweeting this which we all
tweeted seven or eight years ago is
absolutely absolutely astounding he just
one day came to realize truly these
people are vapid and devoid of any
curiosity they don't care what other
people think they make things up they
regurgitate them and that's why we
bought a billboard in Times Square with
special thanks to daily wire for helping
make it happen that says Taylor Lorenz
doxed Libs of tick tock because you
don't get to go on TV and just lie
without getting some pushback so that's
us pushing back even if it's a small
gesture yeah I like your War analogy
because it's kind of like being the
aggressor and attacking someone else and
as soon as they fight back you're like
all we are saying is Give Peace a chance
like dude you guys started this this is
no fault it's not it's not when you
fight back it's when they realize they
might lose yeah yeah they're like oh
wait you mean that guy pick the fight
with actually has is an MMA fighter
actually did you guys see The Joe Rogan
episode with that MMA guy he said that
he he got into politics because he saw
antifa beating up some dude wow and he
tried to pull him off and they start
fighting him and he beat the crap out of
him and then they immediately backed off
realizing he had the power sounds like a
right-wing terrorist to me Tim the left
right now is fascistic they believe
there is no truth but Power antifa uses
violence against people because they
believe in using violence to gain power
when that MMA guy tried saving that dude
and defended himself and they realized
he had more power physically than they
did they retreated no surprise there
well yeah the convictions are only as
are as weak and flabby as their little
arms I'm surprised the local district
attorney didn't land the MMA fighter in
prison seriously no and so the left they
they're basically a metronome and they
very quickly go back and forth between
I'm very tough be scared of me and oh
I'm a poor sweet innocent little victim
someone come protect me
sounds like bipolar someone that's
bipolar sounds like someone who's lying
to gain power yeah somebody whatever
gets them more power they do it this
right guy Robert Reich I remember him
being kind of vocal about Hillary's
emails when that podesta emails dropped
you know 13 000 emails that they ended
up get trying to hide from the public
thirty thousand and he was a big
proponent of of Bernie Sanders at the
time and was really involved with the
like the Progressive Movement as it
seemed like it might actually function
kind of what Trump picked up the reins
of and then he went full TDS trumped
Arrangement syndrome in this hate of
Donald Trump which is like it was just
so Party politics like cult thought so I
thought Reich was really smart until
that now I'm like I don't know he's not
wrong that being social media Monopoly
is dangerous Reich once big government
and big business whereas Trump felt like
look just give people a chance at a
decent wage and you don't need either
and that's where rice basically if you
don't have big government and big
business Russia is out of a job
yeah that's true I think what you'll see
often is
I'd be interested to see what happens on
the right if the right ever gets
institutional power will they become as
hypocritical or will they just defend
their side because now they have the
power and the ability to wield it I kind
of lean towards no because at least over
the past eight or so years the
Republicans have just sat on their hands
and said slow down their Democrats
they've done nothing that's definitely
true I would say if we saw genuine
conservatives real Pro family leaders
take power
there would be corruption because that's
just always going to exist in any Human
Institution but I do believe it would be
much more structured and effective and
honest than anything we're seeing from a
left-wing Authority structure because as
I've said before leftism is just a
synonym for social Decay and they don't
have any real principles so people on
the right have genuine values that they
try to hold to and that they're
accountable to the left doesn't all they
have is the pursuit of power I think
it's a little broad to say leftism just
means social Decay I disagree I think
there is a generational divide I think
modern leftism there's a reason Boomer
is an insult this goes all the way back
to the Boomer 60s and Woodstock and and
the civil rights movement and all that
and you still see it like in my hometown
people are still waiting for that you
know civil rights movement to come back
in their 70 80 years old you know and
it's just the younger Generations have
had enough of it and it's there's going
to be you know it's like a Clash of the
Titans the new generation is being born
and it's what we said earlier with New
Media yeah taking over Legacy Media and
you see these Legacy Media companies
that just don't get New Media you know
they'll pay like hundreds of thousands
of dollars for somebody equally clueless
about how to go viral on New Media when
they can hire the teenager down the
street who's got like a hundred thousand
subscribers or followers on Instagram
I mean you take a look at chicken City
yeah more subscribers in CNN more money
than CNN well they had 150 000 paying
subscribers on a 300 million dollar
initial investment up to a billion so
probably more profit but uh I honestly
do think that chicken city has made or
at least in the first 30 days on track
to make more money than CNN Plus
no no no that that's that's not that's
not true at all but my point is
bringing up chicken city is just because
I think it's hilarious how successful
it's become but uh you were mentioning
it before the show like none of these
people would ever thought won't think of
something like this how do you engage
Community how do you you know you you've
got uh even even the even the daily wire
is doing a really really great job
fighting back they're like we're gonna
make a a children's show and they are
still very much approaching this in a
traditional way with with new with new
technologies and the stuff we're working
on is trying to
be very different much more like a skunk
work or something chicken city was is a
wild and weird idea with chicken parties
but it's very much working in terms of
creating a new kind of family content
well part of why I would argue that I
mean I imagine chicken city is more
profitable than CNN plus because you
have pun intended recouped your costs
CNN plus was how much did you say they
invested 300 million or you are correct
yeah so so you're turning a profit on
chicken city right I mean look a chicken
Rave is more interesting than a Jake
Tapper boat club an absolute terms I
mean the noises aren't all that
different you know but the chickens are
more entertaining to watch you're
talking about thank you
everyone everyone keeps coming into
chicken City and saying is this the view
you're right about Legacy Media not
knowing what they're doing not only do
they not know what they're doing they
don't know who to talk to to figure out
what to do well I think is uh it's not
like oh hey wait Tim Poole seems to
understand viral content let me reach
out and see if he can give me a referral
on how to advertise my whatever you want
yeah there's cognitive moment of
cognitive dissonance where it's like no
that can't be working even though they
see it working it's like that can't be
working it can't be working it takes
like two years before they're like oh it
takes never yeah that's something I
learned about science it's like the old
generation never gets a clue they just
die away and the new generation takes so
what's happening is we've seen that with
like CBS ABC that's Legacy Legacy old
golden age now we've got this this
modern Legacy which is like Facebook
YouTube sorry guys uh Twitter the
centralized services that's going the
way of the dodo as well it's moving
towards federalization Federation and
decentralization so networks that aren't
already focused on that are also going
to start falling away you've seen
Facebook no but it's even with the even
with all the political pressure for
example like rakita media when they did
the Kyle Rittenhouse case they like
eclipsed any of the big three networks
in their coverage because not only was
it like timely they got the feed but
they had intelligent analysis of it
whereas the Legacy networks they they
were caught with their parents not only
that but um I believe for the Johnny
Depp Amber Heard trial right now big
news Rakata law I think is the number
one super chatted channel in the country
this week with their coverage of the
Johnny Depp and Amber Heard Trump they
were great during the race did you guys
watch any of the trials I tuned in I was
like I gotta know we've been talking
about Johnny Depp Amber here I'm like I
just gotta get a taste so I went on and
watched and it's it's John being really
funny and he's just making people laugh
that's why that thing's so popular right
now because he's hilarious wow yeah I
I'm missing out yeah I'm not gonna lie I
try not to pay attention to celebrities
but I did see a couple clips of him
responding to questions well the lawyer
was harassing him and it was genuinely
pretty funny yeah it's like some of the
best thing on TV right now yeah besides
this show yeah of course
um
the danger that these uh these new
Legacy social networks have is that
they're centralized so like the NSA can
go into their database and give them a
gag order and then just take control of
the network so if you have centralized
services like logins and passwords
that's all Legacy stuff man Lids I sent
you my meme about finding the feds in
the data center and I said when Elon
Musk inspects Twitter that's what he's
going to find uh we talked about who's
going to be on the banlist it's the
people yeah
yeah the people that are de-ranked and
don't know it all that's going to start
that's what I'm saying that's my main
issue with Twitter is like the people
who are interesting you just don't see
them and you have no idea why and they
don't have any idea why I wonder how
many people are going to go to prison
maybe it's uh maybe it's a stretch to
assume but I imagine
the testimony that we heard before
Congress
was false
and then Elon Musk is going to have
documents showing Shadow Banning and all
the stuff they claimed they didn't do
the issue however is going to be that
Jack Dorsey is going to be like well at
the time hi Franklin I didn't know that
it was going on and I was acting under
the um the advisement of our legal
counselves you know what they say the
buck stops with the legal counsel it's
not my fault Elon Musk and Jack Dorsey
on this show uh open advice do it would
love to have you that'd be amazing I uh
uh I hit up Joe Rogan I was like you me
Elon Jack Dorsey Twitter uh Twitter
episode round two oh my God but but you
know if whether someone that could
actually happen I kind of feel like I
once again just kind of like shoving
myself in there you have to wait for
Elon to take over Twitter and make
agreements with Jack Dorsey about what
he got gab got Andrew torbo we got
Jeremy Kaufman at Odyssey there's Jack
Dorsey with Twitter now Elon can be
involved and he's a developer he's a
coder man this guy it's so great to have
him at the table I think he bought
Twitter so he could go he's like I want
to be in I read my mind exactly yeah he
can look at the algorithms and figure
out what's up that's the exciting part
it'd be funny if like the only thing he
does is just tweet at some like
celebrity like Sia or something and he's
like yo I would really love to meet you
and hang out and then afterwards he just
sells the company back that's all I
wanted to do like I didn't know I know
how to get a hold of this person so I
I'm rich I am curious what his long-term
plans are he says he wants to make it a
more free speech I know it's long-term
plans somebody was getting public again
once they got way more no he's not
playing take a look at this tweet really
we have this tweet from Trung fun
Hacker News speculating on how Twitter
will integrate with SpaceX for
interplanetary communication someone
wrote this is from generalizations I'm
surprised no one has mentioned that
Twitter is probably the best social
media platform for interplanetary
communication where low bandwidth and
delayed transmission are fundamental
bottlenecks and both limitations are
considered part of the appeal in that
case I wonder if the monetization will
ultimately be based on latency and
message size pay more for your message
to be sent from Mars the next
transmission and pay more to send a
larger message locally I wonder if
Twitter will be tied to starlink in some
fashion think about this Elon Musk
apparently launched some shell companies
and and there might be a single parent
company for SpaceX Tesla and Twitter
he might actually want to make sure
Twitter works because it's the only
social media platform that would work
inter from via interplanetary
Communications Facebook could
theoretically work
but you'd be limited this makes a really
really good point the appeal of Twitter
is character limited limitations in
which case it's optimized for sending
messages back and forth can you send a
software update to the Voyager craft to
tweet
yeah I was about to say I mean look if
if this gets hooked up to seti somehow
or aliens end up seeing Twitter or a
gigantic trouble like this could really
spell disaster for the human race we
send out Voyager with that Golden Disc
or whatever with like basic math and
pictures of humans and then it's like
it's floating out there but what beats
it is the transmission of uh at the
speed of Twitter and so then one day
right right before the Voyager craft
reaches the alien vessel the wave of
Twitter hits the ship and then they see
everything I've never seen a thin person
drink diet coke they're like what is
this well the good the good news is all
that stuff gets scrambled after a
certain number of light years away uh
but the other one is imagine a right
Mars rover that live tweeted that's
highly practical yeah I mean it's really
easy to receive transmissions and
convert them to tweets one of the things
that uh a friend of mine did was he had
you could uh I found that you could use
dial-up internet to tweet and they did
this really interesting way where they
converted the the text into Morse code
Morse code in you know that was then
traveled over the phone line to uh Voice
to Text which converted the morse code
back into text and then tweeted it out
crazy stuff like that when when you had
no means of like Morse code was the
original Twitter come on it's true
people yeah no people try to limit their
character count and I gotta say though
Twitter really did disprove the aphorism
that brevity is the soul of wit because
it's all short it's all the dumbest
thing you've ever read let's talk about
let's just jump to this uh story
actually let's let's do this story right
here check this out welcome to the
Future my friends from timcast.com
Google to begin suggesting inclusive
language Corrections for writers using
docs I've already noticed stuff like
this all right Google Docs I'm actually
very happy about this because
the aim of the new assistive writing
function will be able to help users
avoid Politically Incorrect language
quote but 10 eventually discriminatory
or inappropriate language will be
flagged along with suggestions on how to
make your writing more inclusive and
appropriate for your audience incredible
there's a reason I still use notepad man
well I gotta say I'm actually happy
about this because it will let me know
that there are more offensive ways to
say what I'm currently saying like if I
didn't even realize a phrase was
something people consider to be
upsetting Google will now alert me to
that which I appreciate that so I could
use it more in the doc write it down
yeah I didn't realize that oh this is a
No-No phrase there we go I'll save this
one for next time this is the future
though this is I mean Elon Musk is what
one inch of pushback against a tidal
wave of just Insanity well this is where
Ian talking about Federated systems
being the future is it like I can't
demand like you know we talk about
getting physical copies of media because
anything that's on cloud services gets
censored to death or just wiped from
their servers like you know think of the
movies and how much they've been
censored from like 30 years ago
you know I have a Synology drive at home
where I just keep any movie I want to
keep that's you know been censored well
here's here's what I find fascinating in
the culture War uh we don't we don't do
blackface like people do it ironically
as a joke but this like no one is
legitimately just like doing blackface
stupid right not funny however it used
to be culturally relevant and so we
decided as a society hey this thing we
don't do anymore it's stupid yeah people
don't like it we're gonna avoid it now
as for the comedians who mock the idea I
we don't do that anymore either because
people get canceled but that's the
interesting point we're at a point now
where it seems like something happened I
think it was social media where you used
to have the left pulling all of society
slightly leftward as the right just was
being dragged behind everything drifted
to the left something happened where
that chain between the left and the
right snapped and the left just
immediately lunged a hundred feet
forward and the right stopped moving and
just went wait what well now we're
seeing the left go absolutely insane and
they're determining that things that are
still culturally relevant are no longer
culturally acceptable you end up seeing
things like Ethan Klein he got canceled
twice now do you guys see this again
yeah because he mocked so Ethan Klein of
H3
got uh he lost his sponsors
because he said something about gay
people that he wasn't actually
disparaging them he just had an
incorrect thing oh whoa well you can't
actually you can't say that so he loses
his sponsors he apologized for this and
then like a weaker week and a half later
he then tweets a mock apology mocking
his first apology so now he's getting
Flack all over again this goes well the
point is
he he didn't even make a joke about
somebody he made a statement that he
thought was relevant and it turns out
the left had already moved and left him
behind nothing is keeping them from just
going off and going crazy further and
further off into the progressive
distance well that's what zooby says
he's like I'm just a normal guy from
2012. well am I right wing exactly so
what's happened is
yes things over time become less
culturally acceptable some new things
become culturally acceptable sometimes
we go back a little bit sometimes we go
forward but at this point it's like the
left is changing culture ten times as
fast as culture normally changed and and
we're standing back being like yo you
guys are nuts you've gone too far
probably you can change culture into
thinking men or women and women are men
sorry I mean at that point you know I'm
just going to say it the magic fish is
out of wishes to my theory
things change most quickly when they're
falling apart
maybe maybe the culture is in free fall
so the speed at which we're moving feels
like we're driving fast when actually
it's just just falling apart yeah I mean
they're falling apart but then on the
flip side they're using all sorts of
conservative lingo like triggered and
was it like Patriot takes they're using
the word Patriot to claim that they're
the Patriots no Patriot Texas Mocking
Patriots I know but they're are they yes
like Patriot takes means like a tweet
from a patriot they're mocking you
yeah to be fair well but I think what
you are correct about is that
establishment Democrat types have sort
of co-opted the language of patriotism
over the past couple years right I mean
they talk about Insurrection and like
you know that kind of patriotism and
like protecting our Constitution and
that's why we need to go after j6 it's
like well the purpose of calling it an
Insurrection was to try to disqualify
people like Marjory Taylor green and
Trump right because the 14th Amendment
specifically says if they waged
Insurrection against the United States
so they needed the narrative first so
that people would believe it then they
could file the lawsuits and try and get
it the problem is they move too fast you
you need a generation to instill an idea
that a thing happened
you can't do it in a year and so the
judge in this case
he looks quite the Marjory Taylor green
thing where they're trying to disqualify
her the judge looks absolutely you know
it's funny if you get your news from the
left man these people really warp
reality they're like oh man the judge's
face palming oh it's going so bad for
Marjorie
the whole time I'm watching this trial
the judge keeps telling the the uh the
lawyer against Marjorie he keeps saying
things like what are you doing where are
you going with this what and and
Margera's lawyer subjecting to
everything and the judge just keeps
saying what are you doing like you're
gonna what is this about because he's
asking irrelevant things he's like in
2019 did you tweet this and marjorie's
like yeah and he's like Aha and then and
the lawyer is like how is this relevant
to whether or not on January 6 in or
around she waged Insurrection against
the United States and the judge is like
what's the point of that question it's
like is this an HR meeting I'm trying
I'm trying to establish to us it's just
remarkably bad yeah I mean the Articles
of Confederacy was a pretty
solid case for the southern states doing
an Insurrection I think that's what the
14th amendment was after not because
somebody tweeted that they didn't
believe this election was legitimate or
you know whatever Marjorie Taylor green
said something like today is our 1776
and I think she tweeted that in like
2019 or something and they're like why
would you say that and she's like
because it's like it's on the state seal
like we say it all the time it's a date
that means like Victory and well you saw
they pointed out Nancy Pelosi said the
same thing like about like the summer
riots that this is our 1776 really yeah
of 2020.
that's why I just think it's it's War
and we're we're looking at right now for
the most part A fifth a fifth
generational War so of course they're
going to come out now and they're going
to beg it's that it's that quote we say
and I've never I can never remember the
guy's name that uh you know it's like
when when I am weak or when I'm strong
you ask for Free Speech but it's
according to your principles when I'm
weak I uh or or it's like you know
whatever when you're in power you deny
my free speech because it's according to
your power when you are weak you demand
Free Speech because it gives you power
when I am weak I ask for free speech
because it's according to your
principles when I am strong I deny you
your free speech because it's according
to mine did you guys see the the part of
the uh hearing where the lawyer asked
her if when she said we will not go
quietly into that night whether she was
quoting Independence Day it's like what
so what if image she's like no that's
not what it's called because it's not
originally from Independence Day either
it's an old poem yeah but he's like well
that's from Independence Day right which
is about
the Fourth of July it's like it's about
an alien invasion dude I mean it is it
is fascinating though that he was
attacking Marjorie Taylor green under
the pretext of the Fourth of July 1776
being
bad for the United States it's like
that's our birthday
it's like could you imagine someone
being like today is our birthday what
does that mean are you creating
something new to challenge us yeah it's
ridiculous it is it's my current status
I get the feeling that it was the 2008
the financial crisis when Obama bailed
out Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac it was
basically when it sent everything into a
death spiral in this country fiscally
and now people are like there's no truth
but Power because money's useless now
well also I want to say if you think
America should deny its Heritage as
being a nation which was built upon uh
which was built upon resisting
illegitimate power or a violation of
your rights aren't you the Revolutionary
aren't you the insurrectionist because
aren't you trying to fundamentally
change what this country means and what
it's built upon so the left was smart
about it and seized the institutions
first now they can claim to be the
legitimate institution and you as
someone who upholds the Constitution are
the Revolutionary trying to overthrow
their institutions that's right you the
person who celebrates the people who
literally founded the country want to
emulate them in some way you're the
person trying to overthrow the sacred
order of the nation I think it's
something the Tea Party really helped
Enlighten Americans is about how much
Obama really politicized the state
apparatus in this country and turned it
into you know a Democrat institution
truly one of the darkest presidents
we've ever had Barack Obama and uh he's
a guy who politicized institutions we
had federal agencies going after
right-wing groups you had the extra
judicial Assad fascination of American
citizens you had the indefinite
detention provisions of the ndaa the
lies on top of lies all with a big
smiling face but George Bush Jr was real
probably worse and with the change
called The Cheney Administration that
was pretty at least there was an
opposition to George W bush I mean Obama
is still out there demanding that any of
his critics be silenced and that's scary
yeah the the American population's
response to the Obama presidency was the
most disgusting letdown of my life
that's why I say you know he's one of
the darkest uh one of the darkest
presidencies of uh one of the most
disastrous is because under this veil of
uh
like hope and change we got not only the
same thing but many things that were
actually worse so yeah George W Bush was
okay much darker you know the invasions
was probably some of the darkest days
that we've seen and uh the horrifying
things that came out of all that
absolutely nation building you know for
20 years Barack Obama was really really
bad following up but people abandoned
the fight afterwards and that's that
that you know that hit me hard I talk
about it all the time yeah there's faith
in the leader which was the biggest
problem more faith in yourself I think
both administrations were a disaster for
the American people I do dislike Obama
and the Obama Administration more I'll
say that however you made a point about
Obama talking about how people who
disagree with them should be censored
one thing HW had the decency to do after
leaving the Oval Office was to go away
he went away and he said I'm gonna go
paint my pictures and spend my life
doing that and we don't hear from them
all that often except for when the left
for whatever bizarre reason wants to uh
March him out and go remember when we we
had good Republican leadership unlike
these evil Mega conservatives we have
now even though they hated him and he
started new Wars and was overall a
terrible president but then there's the
scene where like Obama was in a party
with Biden and he looked like he's still
the president and Biden is not even vice
president he's like the mascot or
something like he's just walking around
lost while Obama's shaking everybody's
hand well that come on man that that
clip is he was looking for someone
so everyone shares I really can't stand
this you don't need to try to make Biden
look nuts all right so there's a clip of
Joe Biden walking away from like Obama
talking with people and he's looking
around all confused because he was
supposed to introduce someone to the
group and he couldn't find him and it
was like 10 seconds of him being like
where'd this guy go people grab it and
they're like oh it's so sad look Joe
Biden's lost and I'm like dude come on
you just show him saying Trinidad of
pressure you don't need to take a clip
of him looking for someone being
confused with where the person went act
like he's he's befuddled I hear you on
that but on the other hand given his
behavior in the past doesn't it make
sense that upon seeing that clip a
person would assume this is cognitive
before not him looking the problem is
when people on the right pounce and they
don't do their research I agreed similar
when he turned he looked like he was
shaking hands with a ghost they were
like come on he could have just been
waving no you don't know that he was
actually no he made a deal with the
devil and he was
jump on that one that's the media trying
to justify his his weird Behavior it's
tough to tell you don't you don't finish
a speech and then turn to your right and
hold your hand yeah but he might have
been like wait you know he does that
thing really puts his hands up like
halfway that makes any sense could you
imagine if you did that at the end of a
Tim cast episode because it's like
trying to like shook no one's hand
what did Tim Poole just do can we allow
people who are experiencing that kind of
decline have the power of a podcaster
the media will rush to defense of Joe
Biden when he does something ridiculous
or stupid and many on the right will
rush to say Joe Biden did something
ridiculous or stupid with regardless of
the context typically though you don't
need to try very hard that's why I'm
like dude like Trump don't maybe you
don't need to make me defend the guy you
can point out things you really want to
critique him on and win arguments that
way Joe Biden nine out of 10 times does
something psychotic insane deluded or
deranged one out of ten times it's out
of context and it's like chill on that
we don't need it I'm honestly not even
saying that I'm just saying that clip
showed how like Obama just seems much
more in charge of what's happening in
the Oval Office in Joe Biden what was
the fake word he said it was the one
word that describes America it was just
muttered gibberish oh man
one word describes America you said it
well
it was because he was trying to then
change the subject I guess to I was
hiking the Himalayas with
I was hiking the foothills of the
Himalayas that's right let's talk about
what's going on in uh over in Europe
because of our poor leadership companies
are overwhelmed with inquiries for
nuclear bunkers in Switzerland and
Reporting shortage of materials
following Ukraine Invasion since the
1960s every Swiss municipality had to
build nuclear bunkers for residents
residents are now contacting specialist
companies to build or renovate shelters
the bunkers are being viewed in a new
light since Russia's invasion of Ukraine
what Switzerland needs is 200 gallon
propane tanks for the impending Russian
oil embargo so under uh Donald Trump no
new Wars now
um under Joe Biden
bunkers
nuclear bunkers congratulations I guess
we went from if it saves One Life to how
bad can World War 3 be yeah yes exactly
I mean if it's for a good cause if it
saves One Life we'll vote for Joe Biden
one of the most corrupt individuals to
ever serve government and then Anthony
blinken in in the the defense secretary
Lloyd Austin are like posing with
zelenski
who's the defense secretary what's her
name Lloyd auth to Lloyd Austin's a guy
yeah like
how much more direct involvement in
Ukraine are we gonna get
oh it seems like we're going in I I I
don't know for sure but you know
I I think it's good look Vladimir Putin
Russia they already believe they're at
war with NATO there's no it is in my
opinion ignorant propagandized Americans
who don't understand this point do you
think that Vladimir Putin is sitting
there saying I sent my troops into
Ukraine and they're fighting NATO tanks
and fighter jets that that's just
Ukraine or do you think he's like I'm at
war with NATO
he's at work with NATO all of the
weapons even the people do you think
Vladimir Putin is sitting there watching
American veterans fighting in Ukraine
and he goes well those are just
volunteers or is he saying America NATO
countries are sending people they're
coming in they're being armed by NATO
well I'll put it this way when we found
out that non-government Russian citizens
purchased 46 thousand dollars worth of
Facebook ads related to the 2016
presidential 3600 I'm sorry 4 600. take
out a zero wow so even better help me
make my point even better when that
occurred and we learned that there were
respectable figures in American politics
saying that that was an act of War by
Russia against the United States of
America well the only answer is world
war three obviously yeah let's uh just
just blow it all up it's funny that like
the people who always tell us to go to
war are telling us to go to war now I
mean there must be a good reason I mean
you'll you'll notice something none of
this is going to the U.N
all these like accusations of war crimes
and all of these other accusations
whatever none of it's going to the U.N
because they know I mean they already
know they tried to get a condemnation of
Russia and the rest of the world's like
no we know what you're up to
like sticking a bunch of troops and
artillery on the border of a country of
a sovereign country well that's you know
shocked when they invade to destroy the
Border defenses yeah I mean that's what
uh Putin said when he invaded is he's
like look you're creating an untenable
security situation on my border and
technically by international law I
believe that justifies going in you
can't have terrorists on somebody's
border and and expect them to take it no
I mean Israel and Saudi Arabia do it and
that makes for a very awkward situation
I think the main reason that the
Democratic establishment has been
screaming Russia for so long as they
know that Putin is like one of the one
guy in in Europe that won't fall in line
that they've got everybody bending the
knee to the new plans for their economic
block except for Russia yeah well and
when you can try to when you can
successfully convince a large portion of
the American population that the
presidency is under the control of the
Russian government any time the
president doesn't try to step up
aggressive with Russia they can claim
that it's just evidence that he's bought
and sold by them so and remember when we
opposed the Iraq War we were called
terrorist sympathizers and wait for the
midterms to come in anybody who opposes
our actions in Ukraine is going to be
called a Putin sympathizer exactly so
I'm ready you know it's not my first
rodeo and and back then they said you
don't care about Freedom we need to
fight for freedom and now they go we
need to protect our democracy it's just
more meaningless Buzz phrases we're
protected by securing our borders
bringing manufacturing back focusing on
our infrastructure our roads are
crumbling our bridges are crumbling we
need clean water and places uh in small
cities all over this place we got bad
pipes instead it's just like uh can we
send a billion dollars to Ukraine again
yeah that's what our labor is good for I
guess to go so that's that's the other
thing too it's like if our money is
funding this do the people behind it
really matter if we're if they're
piloting drones even like at what point
it doesn't matter who the person is
behind it it matters who's funding it
yeah yeah absolutely I think there's one
nuclear nuclear bunkers world war three
everybody that's the ballet is what can
the U.S fund and legally in Ukraine and
that's why it's like we can't get
directly involved but we can do land
lease and we can send you know military
experts and advisors and this is this is
what's ridiculous if if I'm watching a
dude throw rocks at me all right am I
going to be like well technically or
I'll put this away if Ian is throwing
rocks at me and Sheamus is handing him
the Rocks am I going to be like Sheamus
is not involved in this hold on a second
no I didn't tell him to do that with the
Rocks but he didn't tell him not to no I
was just passing rocks to Ian Ian goes
Sheamus give me rocks and you're like
you got it buddy and then I'm like I'm
only at war with Ian no Sheamus is doing
nothing wrong the Nazis declared war on
the United States because they were
giving weapons to the British as they
were the Germans were already at war
with the British and then they're like
okay enough's enough can you please stop
first they strive to I think they
started sinking stuff with you both so
that's kind of how they announce their a
war but yeah you lend lease to someone's
enemy they're going to look at you as an
enemy for sure I just don't think Putin
is looking at global domination no he's
any attention once he just wants he
doesn't want Ukraine to become a NATO
country because it means he's got
artillery on his front doorstep I mean
you saw that explosion
yeah I
know he's got enough problems already
but you know he doesn't need one more
um you know you lose that explosion that
happened that was like closer to Moscow
than Kiev
there was some explosion that the Fuel
Depot or something yeah he's got Latvia
in Estonia their NATO country is already
on his border
and you know one other thing notice they
had the worst covid lockdowns in the
world like you could not get a job if
you were not vaccinated you're in Russia
no the Baltic states uh Lithuania and
stuff and like people had to basically
develop a black market and this is what
I keep saying it's geopolitics that's
fueling the um the lockdowns it's like
based on how much the the you EU us
Powers want people to bend the knee uh
to them is is How Deep The lockdowns are
going I think it has a lot to do to do
with oil is my camera broken yeah
apparently my camera's that's weird
because it works over here well this one
works hey look we have a map of uh of
Europe while top of Estonia OBS has
given us is on the fritz axis and allies
here we go I love that game you know we
talked about it before oil has a lot to
do with it um Ukraine is it is it is a
transport for oil it's not the camera
because the cameras
it's clearly working right now it's just
OBS scenes crapped out on us for some
reason we'll have to make like emergency
backup scenes we just don't have
emergency backups for the right one I
wonder why that happens these things are
uh all a part of growing up things
happen yeah but uh anyway the question
is will Vladimir Putin use nukes and do
we need nuclear bunkers he's not going
to use nukes because once he uses nukes
he knows he's lost the War I mean he
becomes a pariah state
yeah Russia would be taken apart by the
global Community if he fired nukes
that's not it's purely a scare tactic
I disagree I think he could uh use a 100
kiloton bomb on Kiev and don't do
anything about it and they're already
they're already they've already been
economically isolated people have
already said he actually has no interest
in Kiev bryansk was where the explosion
happened briennese how do you spell that
one b-r-y-a-n-s-k
bryansk
oh yeah look at that
so what is that about no idea they're
also a string of food plants exploding
do you guys see that also yeah I heard
about that very bizarre and plane
crashes at Food plants so I uh you know
people talk about supply chain
disruptions what we're really in is a
trade war and this is the one like
really digging critique you can make of
trump is he thought he could just
renegotiate trade deals and not disrupt
the geopolitical order because trade
deals are diplomatic deals and he saw it
himself right all of a sudden China is
broke and they can't pay for something
so he had to give them some deal in
order for them to have the money to pay
off something else and now it's like
their their economy is crumbling you
know you had the default and everything
so what we're really seeing is
the entire geopolitical order is
starting to crumble and it needs to
reset not the great reset but it needs
to reset it's something I called out
earlier today I think if if we Prevail
you're going to have a lot of
billionaires bankrupt or in prison by
2030. hmm
what do you mean we Prevail what is that
exactly the New Media people the Elon
Musk you know Elon Musk is like the
future and I don't mean that as a suck
up I mean like he realizes what are the
new technologies what are the new trends
where we can really go into the Next
Generation into 2050 like he believes
global warming is real but he has like
concrete engineering ways to actually
get past it he believes in nuclear
whatever whereas you have this Old Guard
which is like the wef people who
honestly believe like genocide is how
you stop global warming like it's like
you ever saw the movie Moonraker with
with the the James Bond movie Moonraker
it's like Humanity's poisoning the
planet I have to kill them all and
repopulate the planet I mean it's pretty
much like King's Men as well here do you
want us do you want to switch it to my
camera real quick I can try and see if
uh what the heck is the uh the scene was
removed that's what happened so it
accidentally got deleted so uh we've
been using it successfully yeah so it's
it's not there we can't re-edit while
we're currently live regarding climate
change you can pull the carbon dioxide
out of the air and deposit it onto like
carbon Palladium not added the air out
of the water and this is fascinating if
you make water acidic
it will Bubble Up the carbon dioxide and
water as we know from soda water is a
great dissolver of carbon dioxide so
what you do and they're starting to do
this uh explore with with naval ship so
they can produce their own fuel
is they pump in seawater they separate
it into acid they make part acidic part
alkaline sea water the acidic sea water
bubbles up the carbon dioxide and then
they can synthesize that carbon dioxide
back into fuel it's called sin Fuel and
the kicker is it costs about three
dollars a gallon to manufacture it
you've got a carbon negative
way of manufacturing gasoline you could
solve the whole world fuel problem and
global warming at the same time what
will happen is we'll start competing
with the trees we'll be pulling so much
carbon out of the water and the air that
right exactly we'll have to calibrate to
keep it at 350. is this a theoretical
technology or this exists this exists
and there's papers in it I was reading
about it it's it's it's
it's only a matter of scaling it to be
cheap enough you know they said you can
do this on a naval aircraft carrier for
about three dollars a gallon if you did
it on the shore you could probably get
it cheaper because you don't have to
make everything you know portable or
whatever but the idea is just in the
naval situation then you don't have to
constantly go fuel up that Port you
could be out your aircraft carrier
indefinitely like a nuclear submarine or
something there's also a technology
called a micro fragmentation that you
can do with coral where you take Coral
you shatter it into a bunch of different
pieces and you set them all near each
other I fixed it and then they all start
to grow together to regrow coral reef
sort of building ones on other planets
the technology with iron fertilization
to regrow the plankton in the oceans
we're there to heal the Earth we're
pulling the plastic out absolutely
there's so much Tech out there and
that's what bugs me is like all this
global warming stuff that our government
is talking about it's all just pork none
of it is actually it's it's like a
Chernobyl on a global warming level you
know what I mean mean like it's just
going to be another ecological disaster
if our government does what they want to
do it's interesting it's like the
government's job is just to stop
corporations from going crazy not to act
like a corporation
well now that I fixed the camera it's
working again let's go to super chats so
uh for those that are wondering what
happened is we have uh we use we use OBS
and for some reason
the main video feed it just stopped
working so actually so
yeah so I might need to remove one of
them but I don't know which one is the
one to remove now let's do that later
well I don't want the audio I've been
tweeting the sin fuel thing at Elon Musk
I hope he catches up on that yeah let's
talk more about it sin syn fuel yeah
yeah there's another one called Blue
crude which is pretty promising I think
they get that from the air I could be
wrong about that all right we're gonna
go to super chats I think it should be
working now and uh that was very strange
but these bugs happen when you're using
open source software perhaps with your
support as members over at timcast.com
we'll be able to afford better
broadcasting software and uh not with me
on the payroll you know so actually I
will say we have the new studio being
built the foundations has the
foundations done the uh they're gonna be
erecting a steel building it's got uh 25
foot ceiling walls 31 feet in the middle
we're gonna be building this really
incredible Studio it's going to have all
these fun activities the plan right now
is we are going to hybridize our our
workspace in the studio will be fully
skatable
so we're gonna have a bar where you can
have drinks fully made of skate
materials grinding whatever it's going
to be the most hilarious looking work
environment ever cubicles grind all of
them
it's gonna be fantastic it's gonna be
really great having trouble visualizing
this but yeah we're going to have a uh a
stage and you're gonna be able to lift
up the platform and it's a foam pit for
doing flips and stuff so that's awesome
yeah we're gonna we're gonna have this
really cool space where there's gonna be
music and events and we have a bar
people are going to be working and
editing we're gonna be setting up music
studios container buildings we had a
bunch of really crazy ideas it's
currently underway and um with the new
studio means we're going to be upgrading
our equipment so I'll put it that way uh
OBS should not have bugged out I like
that but weird sometimes these things
happen and uh it is what it is if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends head over to
timcast.com and become a member and I'll
tell you why
we're gonna have a members only segment
coming up around 11 or so P.M we do that
Monday through Thursday as a member you
could act access to these segments but
you'll also get something else
we just hired another amazing journalist
we're going to be hiring two more
columnists we're gonna be producing a
whole bunch of content
the more people who started to become
members the more we could afford in
terms of expanding the website we do
need to get on our uh social posting
game more so with the Articles the news
articles we do because we've kind of
slacked on that but the other thing
we'll do is uh I believe I have a
billboard going up tomorrow at 9 00 a.m
in Times Square with the help of the
daily wire
it may be
um
it may be rejected so we'll see because
there's there's rules about how you can
do billboard buys it can't be an
advertisement if you're using other
people's like likenesses or something
like that but it basically just calls it
the Washington Post for lying and it's
very simple it says hey
Taylor Lorenz did this that's it we're
pushing back on their attempted
gaslighting and we're gonna do a lot
more stuff like that so when you super
chat or when you become a member rest
assured we are going to be fighting the
fight now some people have asked with
the Robbie Starbucks thing why don't we
get substantially more involved there
are there are rules and laws around
politics I don't know how to engage with
that but the GOP booting Robbie Starbuck
off the ballot I think is the most
corrupt and dirty thing we've seen in a
long time there's been a lot of
corruption in politics that is as dirty
as it comes as to how we can do anything
about it you got to run into weird
election laws and things like that so
that's where it's more legally
challenging everything is legally
challenging a lot of political 501c4
and there's still like rules and stuff
as to how it's managed absolutely get a
good accountant right all right
everybody let's go to super chats all
right
h-bomb says Hey Ron your Santa Monica
boxing wants a shout out from you and my
Korean brother that's uh Harold gim he's
he I spar with him sometimes great guy
oh cool all right hey moved he's one of
those Californians who moved to Texas
America floats says Twitter might get
based again which would bring about dark
Maga Twitter I want to see it
so I saw some people saying No Light
Maga Trump is the is bringing the light
to save people and he's gonna illuminate
or something like that dark maga's got
its own problems you know I mean it's
the like the issue of Marjorie Taylor
green I I support what she does I hate
what they're doing to her her politics
aren't going to work in California
you know I mean she's great for Georgia
she's great for the people she
represents not going to work in
California and that's a big thing we try
to work on is the California Republicans
are we have our own messaging we have
our own issues
all right Bronson Martin says if Elon
won't sit down with timcast IRL would he
consider an interview with Roberto Jr on
chicken City also acceptable if Elon
just walked into the chicken coop and
started explaining all of his ideas to
the chickens I would absolutely accept
that it would probably make more money
yeah yeah it almost certainly get more
Super chats I mean there'd be a chicken
party like every two seconds Elon Musk
wouldn't be able to get a word in
well the chicken party only triggers
once every five minutes oh so even if
you continually donate the maximum
amount yeah so this actually happens so
that's what happened gave 100 bucks but
the way the algorithm works is that if
the threshold is hit it will it will
wait uh it's on a five minute cycle then
checks has the threshold been hit so if
it hits twice it's just one hit it's
kind of like ordering songs on the
jukebox you just gotta get queued up
right right
all right
Joe Byrne says this is for the billboard
give him hell you guys PS is there any
chance of adding Showgirls to chicken
City
you mean like the hens
chickens chicken city has a bunch of
young chicks naked that's right because
chickens don't wear clothes but uh uh
Joe Brown need to grow up 50 bucks
towards the billboard so uh we'll see
what happens I will be really excited to
see the billboard going up I'm not in
New York but someone will be there I
suppose to film it and I'm sure people
will be tweeting about it so if you live
in New York look out for it I don't know
where it will be uh shout out to Jeremy
boring and the daily wire guys for
helping organize all of this but uh when
I tweeted I was like should I buy a
billboard in Times Square saying Taylor
Lorenz docks Libs of tick tock I I I you
know if they owned it I wouldn't care
that much I'd be like yeah of course
they did it it's the gaslighting that
that really bothers me and it deserves a
proper rebuttal so Jeremy boring
responded I'm in for half and I was like
all right let's do it that's great
you're gonna make that that poor sad
dark place a little bit brighter I
suppose but we we have to say something
we have to do things to be like dude
stop lying to people yeah it's just
they're just lying to people I wonder if
they're gonna have Snopes fact check
your billboard yeah maybe did they
really so you have to stop terrorizing
people I mean look is there was an act
of terrorism I I know we overuse that
word but the the point was to terrorize
the lips of tick tock from operating
right they're going to call this an act
of terrorism though I'm sure somebody
will oh of course they got mad when when
Tucker Carlson talked about her look I
got nothing to say other than Taylor
Lorenz doxxed Libs of tick tock and
let's not forget who employs her which
is you know Washington Post and Jeff
Bezos I mean you know Taylor Lorenz is a
relatively young woman and if you attack
her directly she'll claim oh
it's a meme to insult her because
apparently they think calling him an old
is offensive no literally I checked her
age on Google two different times and
Google gave me two different answers
that's just really because she was born
between 1984 and 1987. there's one of my
tweets how can I believe any of that
okay it's one one of my tweets that
shows she was born 1978 and one tweet
and and born in 19. that's because
people are screwing with her because
they're trying to insult her I am not
playing that game I am pissed off about
ideological issues and about liars in
the media I think it's stupid for people
to be tweeting that she's old because
she's not yeah but if she's lying about
her age she's not she's not this is what
I can't stand right now about so many
people they're tweeting stupid insulting
memes that do nothing but discredit the
fact that this person docks somebody I'm
not gonna sit here and have an argument
about someone's age to try and insult
something is they're lying it's about
her credibility I didn't say this I
agree with him and I'm trying to cut
through the fact that now the
conversation has turned into did she lie
about being old no it's immaterial what
happened was she doxed someone published
their private home address lied about it
on CNN and the Washington Post defended
her and stupid people are turning the
argument is Let's Make fun of her
they're turning the statement and the
argument into making fun of someone
about their age which does nothing to
convince regular people that the media
has been pissing on us and telling us
it's raining you want to go have some
stupid party where a bunch of frat guys
bump their chest and make up lies about
people go do it I'm sick of the lies be
it someone saying she's 49 when she's
not or or her lying to the public about
what's going on in the media let's just
call out the liars I don't care where
they're coming from
my whole point is she's got employers
that want her to do this that pay her to
do this that defend her when she does
that that means there is a chain of
culpability going all the way up to
Washington Post owner which is Jeff
Bezos
that's my problem and she lied and I
would like to call her out and what I
would like to not do is give people fuel
in this stupid argument about all they
do is harass and make up lies I don't
care about her age her age doesn't
matter she could be 10 years old she
could be 30 years old if she's in the
Washington Post and lying and they get a
child to do it I will say the child is
lying right she is an adult journalist
who has posted she has publicly lied on
CNN so we're getting a billboard to say
she did this thing that's it
all right let's read some more Super
chats Eric Miller says Tim you talked
about doing this before but why don't
you hire some protesters to protest the
removing of Robbie Starbucks from the
ballot in downtown Nashville uh as much
as that really pisses me off as well
there are legal issues with that uh I
suppose as a person I could just do it
but there are issues with hiring people
if you have a problem with happened at
Robbie Starbuck and you you're in
Tennessee go join the local Republican
group start your own pack collect your
own money and do it there are plenty of
ways to do it
all right Adrian Contreras says you're
wrong about normal folks needing Heroes
Tim Elon the daily wire or you guys have
the means to fight the fight at this
point every great Army needs generals
kinda deal I agree and so uh we will get
a billboard I'm not entirely convinced
it's it's gonna it's it's the most
powerful thing what I think ultimately
will happen is it will uh it will
generate what's called earned press
meaning it's going to force many of
these people I think I think journalists
will take the bait they're going to be
like look what they're doing they're
going to talk about it but more
importantly a regular person who sees
that might be like I wonder what that's
all about and that's all that really
matters maybe they don't know too much
maybe it's esoteric and then maybe one
day they they hear someone say something
and say oh yeah I saw that thing in
Times Square it said that they doxed
this person
there you go so is there a link on the
ad to go to Tim no well and also I think
it's really important for people to
understand this when they tell lies
oftentimes they don't even try to come
up with an explanation for why their lie
is true they're not interested in
convincing you they just want to repeat
it over and over again so that other
people start thinking it's true and
saying it and so similarly when we
counter them with the truth sometimes
that's our best strategy explain it if
they ask you but you just have to let
people know that you are bold enough to
tell the truth so they feel comfortable
repeating it as well one thing that
really frustrates me is when you know
I'm talking to someone well it's one
thing when I'm talking to someone and
they will make things up outright like
okay we're done it's really annoying
though when I'm talking to like a
leftist or something and then they rebut
with something stupid that has trended
among Libertarians or right-wing
personalities or post-liberals that's
not true and I just wonder like why do
they fall for this stuff stop playing
these games stick to the facts you know
what I really can't stand on on YouTube
this this genre of smack talking people
for dumb things so it's like this
political host talked about this issue
and he's fat and ugly
I mean people do to junk euger all the
time and I'm like wow that's really
convinced my my Boomer family members to
vote for Trump right how about I just
talk about how Trump had no new Wars had
historic peace agreements in Europe and
in the Middle East and we had a booming
economy and I can leave the weird
insulting of people out of this
that's easy to do that's that simple
yep it's low brow and actually I'd be
willing to bet that political operatives
who are aligned with the establishment
be Republican or Democrat know one of
the most powerful ways to discredit a
movement is to get them involved in
drama you get someone to start arguing
about someone's age or looks or
appearance and they're no longer arguing
about issues that actually matter to
regulations I'm not arguing about her
age I'm telling people that she lied
about her age on Twitter she tells
people I'm I'll do the April 12th can we
get some Oprah Lighting in the studio
next time I'm really showing my 43 years
of age on screen I think it's like an
ongoing joke with her but she's lying to
people about her age whether it's a joke
or not yeah I mean I agree with Tim
that's not relevant and you know the
fact is she's getting paid to lie about
people and terrorize people out of the
Public Square
all right Richie Taylor says Tim you're
wrong Elon can't be blocked all the way
to the ISP level Elon thought this
through at the infrastructure level
Tesla and starlink don't need AWS
that's a massive undertaking I mean
Twitter is What's called the fire hose
and there is such a massive flow of
stream of data coming through at any
given moment he's going to need some
powerful infrastructure for that if he's
going to be doing it on his own so maybe
he can maybe he can
that stuff's cheaper than you think
yeah but I just mean the Twitter fire
hose is going to be Hefty that's that's
that's massive there's videos and
there's photos in there whacked out one
says I have the right to protect my
customers regardless of the point
bouncer 101. well that's true so a lot
of people don't seem to understand uh
when I was talking about how a business
can't kick certain people out I'm not
saying they should or shouldn't or
anything that I'm saying quite literally
what we see in the law is someone will
file a lawsuit and claim they were
kicked out for a certain reason or
denied services for a certain reason and
they often win not always we talk about
lawfare on this show right I mean a lot
of this is just lawfare tactics by
activists right I mean
the the the two guys suing the the baker
you know for not baking the cake they're
they were funded by some powerful people
you know same thing with a homeless
situation in La is what I keep saying
the people who are ostensibly homeless
in L.A they they're very well backed
legally and financially by activist
lawyers and they go and make sure the
city does everything by the book or the
city gets sued for like violating their
rights and it's to make a point right
which is that uh if you don't pass our
you know up zoning laws government
housing laws whatever you're gonna keep
seeing people camped out in all your
favorite parks and boulevards
all right Doughboy Johnson says should
any publicly traded company be sued for
fiduciary reasons when they go woke and
stock Falls yes good luck winning
anybody can sue anybody at any time for
any reason but if Twitter says we're
going to deny money for climate we're
going to deny climate change ads they
should be sued granted right now
Twitter's sold so it won't really matter
but if
uh Starbucks they announce we're no
longer you know when they announce the
bathroom thing like we're going to allow
people to use the bathrooms shareholders
should assude and been like that's going
to cost all of us money and you're doing
it for no legitimate reason
now they can argue our customers were
outraged and then you can argue back a
small spattering of activists on Twitter
do not a customer make so Twitter I
think would could potentially lose that
one but that goes back to this whole ESG
thing where all these companies claim
they need to follow like s ESG
guidelines in order to stay in business
and the fact is if they don't they don't
get funding from the banks and you know
so they should be sued
I don't I don't I don't see why we
should say oh poor corporations the
banks are being mean I I'm saying good
luck winning it would be an interesting
lawsuit for sure why do you think you
couldn't win
I'm not a lawyer I'm just that's my
hunch yeah like if a company like
Twitter rejecting ads over climate
change I think is a clearly losing issue
outright granted it's immaterial now
that Elon bought it but to be like we're
not going to take money from potential
customers because we don't like their
ads is telling the shareholders there's
money we could get it but we personally
have an issue okay you can sue Facebook
doesn't do those kinds of ads either
absolutely now the question with
pro-life uh climate change they banned
that would be interesting the thing
about uh pro-life stuff is they have an
argument about offensive or shocking
materials and they can say well we would
lose people get outraged if they saw
offensive stuff in their feed but
there's still an argument of they could
take this money and and provide it in a
certain way to certain only certain
users that have opted in they could uh
you know uh anyway to the point of
climate change climate change is not
objectionable outside of politics
there's actually an interesting case
study with
um tobacco companies cigarette packs
where they wanted to show gruesome
images of like lung cancer and stuff
like that and the courts ruled that the
tobacco companies were not required to
put that kind of shocking imagery on
their own products well that was the
state trying to pass a law saying they
had to do it they wanted they wanted to
force their companies to show really
gruesome things and so that's different
if if Facebook says
for political reasons we have banned
these set of ads there's no there's no
threat to their bottom line I don't know
I don't I don't necessarily agree with
the argument you could sue a company for
denying advertising if you're a
shareholder but the reason is because it
doesn't mean that the company's job is
to take every piece of money they can
get it every time they have to be
judicial about when and where they take
their funds which is my point when it
comes to the pro-life issue they'd be
able to make some arguments on that one
and maybe when when it comes to climate
change they would be denying money for
their personal politics
that's right because it's not even like
you know an issue of you know global
warming is settled or whatever but even
just like you can't even debate the
right way to go about it like you and I
are sitting here discussing interesting
new technologies and you know mocking
Germany for putting solar panels in a
sub-arctic latitude
you know
is that not allowed because if there's
two doctors and they each each have an
advertisement but this one's a little
bit better in your opinion you choose
that ad but not this ad I don't think
they should sue the people for it just
because you like the other AD better
yeah Facebook companies have
responsibility to their shareholders to
make money it makes sense if they say
these ads would offend people and cost
us users and hurt us in the long run
good luck suing on that grounds if they
say climate change we won't we won't
allow any ads that defy consensus on
climate change they have no argument
they'll say are left-wing users would
get mad and then it's like okay well the
current ads you do run make your right
wing users mad you have no argument
there's nothing objectionable in showing
a picture of a tree and saying climate
change this that or otherwise you've
chosen a political stance on this and
have kicked money back for personal
reasons you're costing your shareholders
money
shareholders should revolt
I think their argument is their worried
Barack Obama would get mad and start
passing legislation against them
all right Matt Kelly says this money is
for the billboard in Times Square I love
the idea if there's any left over use it
to pay for the booze that Lauren
Southern drank let me just say the
billboard is already taken care of
and assuming it's approved we'll have it
but um any any if you become a member or
any money you give we will use four more
things like that so I don't know we'll
do more billboards major is out on
billboards for me I feel like it's a you
spend 100 Grand to go turn on a Digi
they have this digital built where they
can just turn on your cartoon and then
turn it off cost them nothing you give
them 100 Grand and then 7 000 people see
it no one clicks on anything they don't
seem like good uh returns these days it
depends on what you're doing and how you
do it even like a multi-pronged approach
there's a rule of seven points of
contact in advertising somebody has to
see your ad like in seven different ways
before they start recognizing your brand
so six more to go to well the issue is
are you good at marketing
buying a billboard and saying I bought a
billboard why isn't it working just
means you're bad at you're bad at
marketing buying so we have this really
great idea for our chicken City
commercial that we're gonna we're doing
for Tucker Carlson and the general idea
is we want to make it be like uh
like what is it like what movie is that
I can't think of the name so there's a
rich guy who wants to plow chicken City
to build a parking lot oh my God so he
gets the city inspector to uh he files
complaints over the chicken constant
chicken parties and the inspector comes
in he's like I don't know chickens
there's too many parties and then you
know the chickens have to team up and
then eventually the city inspector gives
up and says there's no point in fighting
it this is the future and then the old
man is like all right well it wasn't I
think it was like a a Electric Boogaloo
or whatever there was one about I feel
like they've made more than one film
like this there's one about owls when I
was a kid it was called hoot and it was
like a little owl habitat that they're
gonna bulldoze the evil capitalist
people or Goonies no no no Hitchhiker's
Guide to the Galaxy
the rich guy who wants to uh uh you know
One Crazy Summer
I think it's electric Boogle or whatever
okay what's that what's that I've never
seen that yeah he wants to tear it on
the community center to put up a
shopping center or something like that
it's like how many times you're gonna
see this no that was the dance off
wasn't it Electric Boogaloo or something
it's like evil capitalist wants to take
things everyone loves a nose is good to
make money
and then the the so we're gonna do a 30
second movie trailer and part of it is
going to be like if people give five
dollars they can feed the chickens and
once we get 100 we'll have a chicken
party and then we'll raise enough money
to save chicken City dude I can't wait
for them to make a derivative film from
that concept about Elon Musk buying
Twitter and like the evil capitalists
like this this sweet rare bird habitat
we should do we should make that one too
people can't tweet anymore yeah dude
there's so many stories that are just
begging to be told and all it takes is
like the right production company to
tell them like you know you could take
over like the James Bond franchise just
James Bond to me for example is like an
allegory to talk about current events
like the current political situation and
you have like your rhetorical devices
like the the spy and the bond girl and
the villain and all that but behind it
they were always discussing like the
politics of the day like cold war Russia
you know or the 80s Taliban or global
warming and the environmental movement
right cool a Bond movie about global
would be cool but it doesn't have to be
Bond just like a spy movie about global
warming well that's what I'm saying it's
like Moonraker it's like this guy thing
sort of destroying the planet and
yeah is that what Jaws was that
Moonraker yeah Jaws did you ever find
the space shuttle they fly in a space
shuttle to the space station with the
the guy and they they sneak onto the
freaking space station with the space
shuttle
it's been done uh I was a big fan of
GoldenEye did you ever watch that one I
looked it's been so long played
GoldenEye yeah never yeah I never saw
any of the films from that era
well yeah someone someone uh just
tweeted uh mentioned
uh this is uh Joel boy malice just
tweeted that he's meeting Elon and uh
yeah Michael oh wow Michael Mouse did
tweet he says I've accepted a meeting
with Elon Musk about the future of
Twitter free speech and social media in
general hey Michael malice Unblock Me
you jerk oh snap so I tweeted at Michael
Michael have Elon come on the show with
you yes and then I'll ask Jack Dorsey as
well and we'll just you know just kind
of talk about stuff do like a long
episode
Jack Dorsey and Elon Musk in the same
room man that sparks flying right there
yeah
all right
final six warnings has Tim just nailed
it the culture wars are the ruling
classes wet dream keeping us all
distracted with infighting while they
have their way with all of us left
versus right is the minor leagues it is
the minor leagues and so uh there's that
famous quote that's basically like do
you guys remember it it's you know
stupid people talk about people and oh
yeah it's Eleanor Roosevelt yeah Simple
Minds talk about people talk about
events great minds talk about ideas
right
so uh we do a little bit of all of that
because you have to because people have
effects and their ideas but I think the
most important thing is you know we are
mediocre Minds here talking about events
all day also on top of that we talk
about the ideas behind them I can't take
credit for this observation but it
should be pointed out that that quote is
in fact talking about people yeah I had
a thought about this the culture wars
that it's inverted from a hot war and
that if you fight in the culture where
you lose but if you create I will tell
you that if you want to fight for a
cause you're gonna be fighting with
people you know people get into politics
thinking I believe in this and that and
then they get smeared because the their
opponents have a political vested
interest in stopping that it's like I
said with when it comes to like our
Police Department or up zoning you got
definite people are pushing for that and
if you fight them if you disagree with
them on any of their agenda they'll come
and smear you people were like because I
said if you fight this in the culture
where you lose on that's how they get
you to lose is to get to fight them but
you create they're like well isn't
creating a form of fighting no creating
is creating you might consider it a form
of uh competition to create something
better than what they have but fighting
them is different than creating
something new right no you you fight
them by going around them we've got
breaking news Michael malice tweeted
that he accepted this meeting I
responded ask him to come on timcast IRL
with you to which Michael responded he
wants to blaze it with Ian Crossland
badass all right let's get fired up boys
so this is actually no in all
seriousness Michael if you are if you
are listening or we'll tweet you uh Ian
Eon having experience with minds.com and
moderation all that stuff I think would
be very beneficial in this context too
so even if the only thing that happens
is you know Ian ends up talking to Elon
a little bit about your experience with
Minds decentralization yeah the jury
system you brought that up before the
show and it forms a moderation relying
on Elon to have to do that's going to
make him frustrated and a lot of enemies
but if you create a jury system in the
site where the site the people using it
can modify and moderate together as a
cohesive decentralized unit that's a
good tactic we'll talk more about it so
uh mines did this it's actually really
simple it's it's trying to create the
same standards we have in in Civil Life
a jury system if you're accused of doing
wrong then a jury of your peers will
review the evidence and determine
whether or not they agree with the
charges against you instead of having
some nebulous organization behind the
scenes deciding who or what is worthy of
being banned if someone breaks the rules
then people can be selected for jury
duty they can then opt in and like it
will it will be like hey you may see you
know violent imagery you may see things
you may not like this is a warning you
can say no some people might then choose
okay show me what this person did
they'll say here's what they said or
post it does it break the rules and the
jury can then issue their vote and then
we'd have to figure out was it like a
two-thirds Vote or a unanimous vote sure
yeah that's all to be determined that's
this kind of thing the admins can talk
about that's fun and do you think oh no
that's an interesting feature with bird
watch that they could expand on you know
I'm actually a bird watch contributor
where you can put a note on somebody's
tweet to say whether it's misleading or
not and then you rate other notes on
that tweet to say whether those notes on
the Tweet are are helpful or not so you
know you get a lot of people who say
that's false and this person's a poopy
head and the Putin apologist and they're
like this is not helpful you know so
that helps and I think yeah
I think yeah too man we're going there
hard everybody no I think Twitter does
make some kind of reasonable effort to
moderate conversations for the better
and have algorithms that rate whether
people want to see your stuff or not the
problem is it just gets human override
way too much based on like way too many
passive aggressive you know feelings
about specific people I think any
uh algorithm or code to determine what
people want or don't want is wrong and
should be removed or at least make trans
it needs to be transparent I think it's
a good thing and then you can remove it
if you want if you want an opt-in system
like Twitter has the algorithmic feed
the home or the chronological feed I
think that's fine but anytime someone
says we're going to try and determine
what people like they end up censoring
people and it makes things bad there
needs to be an opportunity for people
with crazy ideas to express them you
can't just get rid of it because most 51
of people say Trump is bad oh now
Trump's gone no we can't do that anyway
my friends if you haven't people are
saying Mouse is trolling I know he's
trolling I don't care Michael
tell Elon to blaze it with Ian Crossland
I'll come on the show and I'll I'll I'll
I'll see if Jack's interested I don't
know if he can or would be but we'll try
to make something really really cool
happen uh if you haven't already smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show if you really do
like it we are uh trying to spread the
values of personal responsibility and
freedom I suppose it's all right wing
these days but I don't think it is I
think those are just core tenets of good
behavior so uh smash the like button
subscribe to the channel head over to
timcast.com we're going to have a
members only segment coming up and uh uh
we'll have that for you around 11 or so
p.m you can follow the show at
timcastirl you can follow me at
timcastron do you want to shout anything
out
shh why can't I shout out I don't I mean
you know
something I wanted to talk to you about
for a while is just how you know we got
new media and new stories uh that are
just begging to be told I wrote this
book inferno Los Angeles Inferno
losangeles.com
um it's a story Dante's Inferno based in
the modern world I think these stories
need to be told I hope you see more of
those
you start producing stories like that we
got we got a new book coming out soon we
got Tales from the inverted world the
first one we got the new ghosts of the
Civil War coming out soon I'm really
excited for this so uh we'll see yeah
I'm really excited about a new
generation of stories because this old
media they're just committing suicide
nobody wants to watch their stuff
right on and let's write a joint
autobiography one chapter your life one
chapter my life boom really as long as
there's a joints
[Laughter]
do I get the job I am Sheamus I make
YouTube cartoons on a channel called
Freedom Tunes you guys could see that
just by typing Freedom tunes into
YouTube we're gonna be releasing a video
on Thursday I think you all will enjoy
it I'll write a joint book with you
called the light and the dark and it's
just like toggle between our
consciousnesses and like it'll seem
almost like are you familiar with
psychotic are you familiar with it they
call this an art school it's an exercise
called the Exquisite corpse where you
see like so basically an art you see
where the the person other person's
lines were and try to draw based on that
but it's like you see the last sentence
someone wrote in a long story and you
try to pick it up from there and it
never makes sense that could be a funny
thing all right perfect for us then
that's great for me uh bye guys Ian
Crossland catch you later Ron Garcia I
want to shout out your Twitter before we
rolled it was uh what is it Ron for
California the number four that's right
all right guys we I'll catch you all
tomorrow see you later take care guys
for tuning in as always wait I really
like I wanted to point out Ron's awesome
shirt I think he has Cthulhu on it yeah
cool I was loving it before the show I
was looking at it really closely it
looked a little bit like a funky Leaf
but I just one to check it's not it's
way cooler anyway guys anyway you guys
may follow me on Twitter at sarahpatrids
as well as mines.com and at sourpatch
let's stop me we will see you all over
at timcast.com thanks for hanging out
bye guys